Where's the music?
There's the music.
Hello everybody!
Welcome to...
Welcome back to Metal Gear Solid 2!
Hello, hello.
Once I get my controller is...
under some cables.
Alright.
Okay.
I have like a very strange setup here because I have my game
cube and then also my ps2 so it's like all these things that
i kind of haphazardly set up because i was like i'm lazy i
don't feel like making all the wires are kind of everywhere
don't worry about it say it boss for old time's sake
kept you waiting huh
how's my chair actually um it was an easier fix than i
thought um but i still don't know how it came undone very
strange for those who don't know um i did a hand cam stream
yesterday and my chair broke on stream um i don't know how
it did that there's no bolt missing or anything no nuts
around um i don't know it's very weird she said that thing
hey id welcome to membership and dog to the five gifted you
guys i will be getting new emotes i gave a little bit of a
preview in the members tab community tab and then some in
pre-chat too yeah yippee it's actually two different artists
so um i'm going to because i separated them i'm basically
waiting i'm gonna one of them's already done but i'm gonna
wait for the other artists as well so that i can release
them all together so yeah yeah yeah i got into mgs because
of you what do you do to me i'm just spreading the good word
i'm spreading the good word of metal gear yeah chair
sabotage by the lalilulelo so true so true finally i am
green you hello mint hello hello hello do you have a
favorite voice line in mgs2
that is tough
i think honestly it's any of ryden's internal monologues i
think yeah what a weirdo i love that one i love i love What
an egotistical woman.
I love that one.
Oh, you're a real egotistical woman.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Vivi Kaur, thanks for the five gifted.
I love infinite ammo.
Oh my gosh, what do you point to it?
Oh, let me also...
I will post my spoiler for you thing.
If Min's chair is broken, we shall become her chair.
Dibs on the footrest.
Stab!
TV table tray, thanks for the 10 gifted.
Thank you so much.
Not even a poster.
Oh my gosh, yes.
I love when there's too many iconic things.
But I think what I quote the most is literally Ryden's
internal monologues.
Which maybe are not the more iconic things from the game.
You know, you have stuff like a dud.
And we've managed to avoid drowning.
You know, get real.
too much.
But I quote those all the time.
You got me into MGS and it's so much fun.
Thanks, Vies.
Of course.
Thank you, Shy Guy.
Let's see.
Okay, please no spoilers in the chat.
Not for me, but for anyone who may be joining us and
watching MGS for the first time.
Thank you.
Replace pinned message.
Sorry again about the time change.
If you're watching the VOD.
Hello, thanks for watching the VOD.
But if you're here, thank you so much.
I'm so sorry that I had to change it.
I did a little whoopsie in my brain with my schedule.
And kind of had to adjust a little bit.
Do it yourself is my fave.
Get a Herman Miller, then name it Master Miller.
But aren't Herman Miller's super duper expensive, right?
Do we still hide the spoilers with smiley faces?
Yes!
if you wouldn't mind, you know.
I'll do my best as well.
Again, I know we get a little bit excited.
But, um, yeah.
Um, earlier in the day is...
Earlier time is more convenient for me.
Yippee!
Yeah, I know.
Sometimes it'll be more convenient for some people.
And it was, like, kind of last minute that I had to change
the time.
So, I'm so sorry.
No, that is not Solid Snake.
Oh, my gosh.
Yes, that's so good, too.
but um used ones for cheap when offices remodeled oh are
they that nice though like are they that comfy i actually
really like my chair i've had it for several years now hugo
welcome the membership thank you mgs on my birthday can i
get a happy birthday mint of course happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you Happy birthday, Jay Frosty.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday.
If anyone can justify an expensive chair, a successful
full-time streamer with backbench.
Why are you calling me now?
Oh my gosh, I don't have my good contacts in, so it's hard
to see.
see sometimes.
Mistays, mistyze, mistyze, thanks for three months.
Master Miller chairman.
It's writing a message about, oh my gosh, I read that as
MGS, a message about the time someone mentioned Herman
Miller get it, it is life changing.
I got one for $400 from a secondhand distro because offices,
I'm using this to put the shill it.
Oh, treat yourself, dummy.
You guys, I almost, I tried to treat myself today.
There was a bubble tea place that opened near my maid cafe,
and I was like, I'm gonna go get bubble tea!
I was gonna treat myself, and it wasn't open yet.
It wasn't open yet.
I didn't get it.
Instead, I got cake.
Instead, I went to the store and I was like, fine, I'll just
go get cake.
And I ate one bite of it.
And then I put it in my fridge.
Because that's what I do.
I'm going to eat one bite of it.
And then put it back in my fridge.
Brick!
A Minto Gear Solid Stream on my birthday!
It's the perfect present.
How did you know?
Oh my gosh!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Brick.
Happy birthday to you Happy birthday Okay, Saku, I'll be on
the lookout for you Sending me the place that you got your
chair I'll look into them I'll look into them My chair is
perfectly fine though, you know So it's like It's hard to
justify dropping not much money Well, I say perfectly fine,
it broke last night But I think it's okay now You know?
But then there's also me who's just like, gosh.
I'll waste money.
I spend my money on like things that I don't need sometimes.
Like Metal Gear merch.
But also I'll be like, oh, what if I just upgrade my
computer and get a new graphics card?
Because I want my PC to be all white and aesthetic when my
graphics card is perfectly fine but also i use my graphics
card every day so like what about but like also what if i
just you know spray paint it oh my gosh but sorry my
contacts are so bad today oh sounds like a business expense
to me you're so right though and then i was also looking at
the height um they have like the pc cases that have that
have like the little screen on them And I was like, I could
put something on that.
What could I put on that?
Oh my gosh, Nexi!
Thank you.
Thank you, Master Miller.
Terran, thank you.
I summoned a loose screw for Minto to buy chairs.
Yeah.
Going to get a Doki case.
It's too yellow.
Right now, right now, wait, I just realized some of my
lights aren't on.
Right now, my...
my setup is like pink and blue but also I have the Corsair
like fans but they're off colored I don't think they're like
if I set it to like red it's or pink it turns more like
orange makes me so sad
get Doki to play Metal Gear to see her reaction I don't know
I don't know if she would like Metal Gear.
Mint case.
Hmm.
Have I played Metal Gear Rising Revengeance on stream?
Not yet!
We'll play it eventually once we get through the series.
Too much cutscene for her small bird brain, you think?
MGS is too much thinking.
You guys are roasting.
her you guys are roasting her wow no but i do think maybe i
don't know she played what sandland but she doesn't
typically do like games that are so long you know what i
mean she might like five i think she would like to play five
probably right it's a thinker man's game This is your least
favorite?
Uh, five.
But only...
Only because of...
The story.
The gameplay is top tier.
Even a pigeon would have a better time at edges.
Five for the writing, yeah.
That's...
But five for the gameplay is my favorite.
The gameplay is 10 out of 10.
So great.
Not because of Kiefer.
He's fine.
I played 5 first.
I think it'd be a good intro.
What?
Wait.
Are you...
Are you being sarcastic?
How can you play 5 before you play Peace Walker?
I don't understand.
But...
Yeah, going back to the Key for Sutherland thing, I actually
don't mind him voicing Venom because I think if I heard
David Hader be so brooding and sad, I might be like, I can't
deal with this.
Love how you scared Doki with Freddy the screen.
Truly a cinema moment.
I feel like Metal Gear, I'm guessing you like bipedal war
machines in a good way.
Titanfall 2.
I do like...
I do...
Machine.
Yes.
Oh!
That reminds me.
I, um...
Was going through some of my stuff from Offkaai.
Like, I got a big old package.
And it's kind of just been sitting in, like, the...
In the box that got sent to me.
And there were some things in there that...
I didn't even see before they were sent out.
like someone I'm gonna say your Twitter name because that's
what you wrote on it Angel Milk 42 thank you for the ICOTS
book if you're watching and someone gifted me like the
Phantom Pain hand and then a steel book case of the Phantom
Pain so thank you hmm hmm 10,000% seriousness?
No!
The lore and weirdness hooked my brain.
I knew the vague snake story because friends are obsessed.
I shut up.
We'll ride in.
No!
You don't even know who Aslan is.
You don't even know who Miller is.
You don't even know who Chico is.
You don't even know who Paus is.
You don't even know who Snake is.
There's no reason to play.
five before you played anything else you don't know what's
going on how could you know what's going on how could you
know how could you know how could you know what's happening
you would just go in you'd be like so confused if you didn't
even play ground zeros okay at least play ground zeros but
then you're still just like I don't even know what mother
base is I don't know what MSF is I don't know who Chico I
don't know Paris I don't know why why should I care about
paws blowing up oh don't play five first
God!
There's my aneurysm.
Oh my gosh, I'm starting to see black.
Hold on, I'm taking this.
What'd you say, dog strings?
I'm going to Aniribo this year.
I was hyped to hear you joining Doki for a bit.
Yeah!
Mm-hmm.
Doing our concert together.
They gotta start with Peace Walker.
Peace Walker, GZ, Peace Walk, oh wait.
Peace Walker, GZ, and Peace Wait, and Peace Walk.
You mean Pantheon?
No.
Make up MGS5.
Yes.
But then you can't play Peace Walker without playing three.
You see the problem here?
Then you have to you can't play three without playing one or
two.
You don't know who Oslo is.
You don't know anything about the Patriots.
You don't know anything.
You don't know... Well, I guess you learn about the
Philosopher's Legacy.
Wait, do they mention the Philosopher's Legacy in this game?
I'm trying not to talk about spoilers.
But you don't know anything!
You don't know anything!
You have to start in the beginning!
Oh no, she's nerding out.
Calm down, Min.
I'm sorry.
They don't mention in this game.
Okay, but...
There's the spoilers at the end of the game.
The little call with...
With...
With about...
About...
About the la la la...
Wait for Delta, the best way to get into Metal Gear.
Truly though, I think Delta will get so many people playing
Metal Gear for the first time.
I'm quite excited about it, but I'm also just like...
Ocelot.
You just...
You just won't understand!
Gotta start at Snatchers or Psychonauts.
Okay, I am done talking about Metal Gear for so long.
You gotta start MGS by watching a playthrough.
Go, sure!
Thank you for the birthday gift!
Thank you so much!
Which MGS game did you play firsthand?
Oh, Metal Gear...
Oh, sorry, which MGS?
Of course, I started at Metal Gear Solid 1.
What are you talking about?
Now if you would ask me which Metal Gear I started at that's
a different story But you specifically said which MGS did
you start at and MGS Metal Gear Solid is its own thing and
then Metal Gear Rising That's MGR, you know, so it's you
know, it's it's like it's it's you know, it's the specifics
The specifics matter Right, yeah Mm-hmm
semantics yep yep they're important what if i play phantom
pain and nothing else
what a nerd but yeah um let's see last time we left off we
are about to diffuse some bombs uh we got our smelly
detector hold on i'm holding it i'm putting it over chat
Peeppepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepe
Can you sing me happy birthday?
Also, can't wait to see our...
Oh, Taku-dan!
Thank you!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday!
Nuts on fire!
Happy birthday to you!
I spoiled a little bit?
Oh, I mentioned Paz.
Oh.
Yeah.
Okay.
That was my bad.
That was a ground zero spoiler.
My bad.
But, um.
You mentioned so much.
No, I didn't.
We are not solid something.
Paz is my cat.
She's so cute.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
Last night, I was doing my face mask.
I walk into my bedroom and both of my cats are laying where
I'm supposed to lay they're like right underneath my pillow
and it's the first time usually pause sleeps at my feet but
this was the first time this was the first time she laid
close to my head I was so happy I was so happy and then this
morning I went to feed her and she was laying down and she
stood up and she stretched and she nastiest fart you guys I
think I have to rename her to Johnny real I think I really
need to take her to the vet for her I think she has I think
she has I think she has like a real problem sometimes she
gets like drippy and just like drips poop everywhere I'm
constantly having to clean she hasn't in a while though but
i i really need to take her to the vet but i was so focused
on but on but i hadn't been able to um take her i was like
focusing on him first i'm just constantly going to the vet
over and over and over again yeah not the stinky duo she's
like legitimately stinky rip the people eating while
watching the stream i'm so sorry but yeah butaro is eating
better he is but he's like i think he has like food anxiety
now because he was hungry for so long because he wasn't able
to eat but now he's like constantly constantly constantly
begging for food so i'm constantly constantly constantly
having to feed him but he eats it up it's up so uh but he's
been eating a lot and gaining weight so i'm happy about that
and he hasn't been throwing up so it's been good it's been
pretty good all things considered yeah okay it's been a half
hour i'm loading the game um let me know how the audio is
and everything too um this one
I wonder where it's going to put us.
Stinky.
Where am I?
Okay, hold on.
I have to remember how to play the game.
Ryden's behind looks very good here.
Wowie!
Oh my goodness!
Look at that!
My lumps!
My lovely lady lumps!
Wow!
Oh, there we go.
Wowie.
Okay.
Oh,
this is where a snake went.
Oh, my gosh.
That scared the badonkas out of me.
Oh, bliss can win that way.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh.
Who am I talking about?
So a guy comes down this way?
What am I hearing making a buzzing sound?
No, it's not solid snake.
I totally...
You know how...
Like, okay, so sorry.
I was reading some fan theories online that said that...
That maybe Pliskin is solid snake, but I think it's totally
BS.
Yeah, Snake died.
It's really sad.
Shoot.
Wait.
Okay, okay.
Just got here for my favorite soap opera.
Starting Ryden and Rose.
Why am I forgetting everything on how to play this game
again?
Oh my goodness.
Okay.
Where did that guy go anyway?
Do you think he'll see me right here?
I know, I know.
I gotta find the nerd.
I think there's this guy and then there's also...
Do you guys hear that buzzing?
Or is it just me?
Do you guys hear a buzzing or is it just...
Oh, it's driving me insane.
Oh, it's the bugs at the doorway!
Oh, my gosh.
They're driving me actually insane.
Come on, guy.
Come back, please.
Oh, here it comes.
Here it comes.
I'm too scared.
I'm too...
Oh, my God.
Wait, wait, wait.
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait where is he i'm too scared to move i gotta get back
into it i gotta get back into it knock on the wall i'm
scared sorry i'm gonna get i'm gonna take a second to get
used to i don't know why i'm feeling so strange about the
game all the sudden like i feel like i'm a baby like i've
just been thrown into something i don't even know what i'm
doing i
don't know why i'm feeling so uh uncomfortable i think is
the right word i'm feeling uncomfortable i don't know why
hello please come back you're taking i'm sick of these bugs
i just i just want to i just want to get used to the game
but you're making me uncomfortable you're becoming too much
like riding
where is he wait oh i think he's coming
I hear him.
My hands are cramping.
Um.
Good night.
Okay.
I think there is a guy.
Oh.
Isn't there a guy in here?
Where's the nerd at?
No, I'm still...
I'm still hearing the...
I don't hear the buzzing anymore.
Huh.
I don't hear it when I paused.
Bottom right?
Down here?
No.
Where's the nerd?
Oh, shut up!
I hate you guys!
See the guy that was wandering this room?
Oh, no, no, no.
Oh,
my God.
I saw it, though.
There we go.
All right, come on.
Sorry.
Oh, my gosh.
I don't know why I'm feeling so weird.
Anxious, anxious.
So we have this.
This is finding our stinky of stinkyness.
Do you have anything for me?
Any lockers in here?
Hmm.
Take that, though.
Could I stick him in here?
I was like, who else do I hear asleep?
Hey, let me in.
everything's okay in here get to work on those bombs okay
the toilets could we put them in there it's fine we'll just
leave i hear a buzzing i hate them okay first bomb um is up
here
hey right in here I took care of the C4 in Strut C the
ceiling of the women's bathroom was set to blow our big boss
anything wrong maybe Pliskin's reported other locations too
and none of them are effective demolition points what do you
mean it means that they wouldn't be the best places to
choose if you wanted to destroy this place are you saying
they don't plan on blowing the shell up it certainly seems
that way so far we haven't seen anything but a waste of good
explosives unless of course we're missing something a trap
he couldn't have overlooked the fact that I would be called
into this there's something going on right right whatever
all right let's go back to this place whatever is there a
way for us to send you fan letter if we do is there a
certain letter writing protocol we should follow um I don't
really have a place to send fan letters, unfortunately.
Um, I appreciate you...
Oh, and it's gone.
I appreciate you wanting to.
Um, and if you ever...
If I ever do have a way for you to send fan letters, you
can...
It's not like, you know, we could just re-ammer on about
random stuff we're doing.
Yeah, you could always just...
It doesn't have to be like a...
A set whatever.
It can just be something.
Hello?
Oh, there it is.
Shoot.
There we go.
Fortune was there.
That's where the dud happened.
The dud.
Can you receive psychic messages?
Ouija board summonings.
I try to ignore the Ouija board stuff.
Because, um,
where is it here?
I don't remember, actually.
I hear it, like, right here.
I don't remember where it's at.
Where does that guy go?
Does he come through here?
He's not gonna hear me.
I don't think it's in here, is it?
No, it can't be in the locker.
Oh, let's put this guy in the locker, though.
Come here.
Come here, Robbie.
Oh, come here.
Come on, come on, come on.
Oh, wait.
I'm going to have to wait for this guy to loop around again.
If you would stop snoring so loudly, maybe.
Good night.
Good night, sweet prince.
And there's another one for this guy, too.
Where is he?
Where is the guy in here?
Oh, oh, shoot.
Oh, he's coming this way.
We'll get him.
We'll get him once he starts walking away.
There we go.
Good night, little babies.
What do you got for me?
I'll take that.
Good night, little babies.
Good aim, boss.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't remember where this one is, though.
And now they go into the locker and they don't wake up.
Good night.
Okay, perfect.
One for each guy.
Okay.
Where was it again?
It stinks in here.
Not in here.
I hear it.
Or I heard it.
This area is so vague.
This one is so sneaky.
Because it's smelly everywhere, but then you hear it here.
So, like, it's so confusing.
Why are you so sneaky?
I can't remember at all where it's at.
Is that in the doorway?
Hello.
Do I need to crawl?
I just leave all the blood and everything.
Why can I hear it?
Maybe it's on the other side.
But I don't hear...
Oh, I heard it.
Wait.
Beep, beep, beep.
What the?
Crawl on the ground like a baby?
Should I cry like a baby too?
Thank you so much for the 30 gifts.
Okay, I'm annoying myself.
I'm even annoying myself.
I know you're going to say no alp.
Could I get a hint?
I don't remember at all where it is.
I don't remember it all.
Those doors close.
Oh my god!
Thanks for the alp.
Yippee!
All right.
Onward we go.
Where else do we need to go?
Hold on, I'm gonna call.
Please can't.
I'm done with one more C4.
Me too!
This one was in a spot so narrow I had to crawl in to get at
it.
Oh, we're gonna have to do that too later on.
Stillman, where do I go?
Leah!
Riding reporting.
The C4 in Strut B has been disposed of.
The wall containing the transformer panel was set to blow.
You're taking too much time.
You should work a little faster.
Sorry.
There's no time, Riding.
I've got my hands full here, so it doesn't look like I can
help you.
Okay, now what he asked you.
It's in your hand.
Well done.
It looks like there are no more bombs in that strut.
Wait, what?
Now, head for the other struts.
Huh?
Ride in with his gaming posture.
Run.
I love it.
L-A-L-L-L-L- wait.
L-A-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L.
Head to the other struts.
Oh.
No!
I just missed.
Oh.
Good night.
Come back here so I can loot you, please.
Thank you.
Okay.
M9 is such a good gun.
I know.
Oh my gosh.
It's just so nice.
It's just so nice having it.
Though I wish I had a suppressor on my my other one hello
hello you little cheesy give me something give me a present
oh there we go i think they meant the real m9 this is the
real m9 what are you talking about is it stinky in here or
is it you guys Oh my god.
There's somebody there.
Get inside.
Get inside, Raiden.
Raiden, close the door.
Raiden, close the door!
Oh god.
Okay, never mind.
Gosh, Raiden, you scared me.
Oh, I see smelly.
I see smelly.
It's upstairs, I think.
Oh, I think I have to go...
How do I get over to that area?
What?
How did I...
No, there's not.
Just, uh...
Where's my box?
Where is my box?
Hello?
Wait.
I forgot it picked it up as, uh...
a snake yeah I never got the box how did he see me this guy
has eyes of a hawk for real
oh my god he's the one that got me last time too so scared
of him oh I'm so scared of this guy.
Okay.
Where do I go?
This way?
Oh!
Okay, it's this room.
Okay, I know this room.
Oh my gosh.
Is there a locker in here stuff you're in so I can take my
time?
If I shoot that, the guy in the other room will probably
hear.
I think.
Is there a locker in here?
No, that's not a locker.
A box!
You guys say no Elp.
You guys say no Elp there.
Is the Elp right there?
I think I might have to take him out, you guys.
I think...
Oh, I have to tranquilize him as well.
You're right.
Okay, let's get that.
I think if I do it right here...
Will he see me?
Please don't see me.
Oh, dang it.
He doesn't go far enough.
That's okay.
We'll just have to be speedy fast about it.
Now I have to remember how I did this before.
All right, Raiden, crawl, crawl, crawl, crawl this way.
Craw, crawl, Raiden, Raiden, I said we need to be speedy.
Come on, okay, crawl this way.
He's waking up, no he's not.
This way.
Crawl, crawl, crawl.
Will he be able to see me?
Nice.
Which way do I go?
Oh shoot, I don't remember.
What?
What do you want?
No one's going to leave a bomb in a place that easy to
reach.
It would be more worthwhile to search convoluted areas that
can't be reached simply by walking.
I'm working on it!
Stilman, please!
Let me do my job!
God, I'm working on my art!
Oh, I get through again.
It's like over there.
And remember where it is.
I just...
just want to say that you were the cutest stop it i'm too
slow i know
okay he's got two z's
sleep i really want to take out this other guy so i can
freely roll actually i really just want to shoot him i
really just want to take him out and general but I'm too
good of a person it's right there isn't it it's like right
there I think yeah I see it I literally see it can
I go through here no wait I think I can go through right
here
And then, can I go on top of this?
Yeah.
Okay.
And we get our box!
Yippee!
Wait, can I go through here?
Nope.
Okay, hold on.
I'm figuring it out.
How do I get over there?
That's right.
Come on, Raiden.
Just use your hands.
Raiden, just...
Raiden, just use your hands.
Raiden, please.
Raiden.
Oh my gosh, it's right there!
How do I get through?
Ryden, Ryden.
Call Pliskin.
What's he got to say?
Does he know this place?
Me?
Ryden, don't get yourself worked up.
I'm worked up!
It's safer to take out the enemy first, then look for the
bomb.
Don't even think about searching for the bomb shoulder for
the enemy.
Knock them unconscious or take them out altogether.
He's giving me permission!
He's giving me permission to take them out.
I mean, it's Pliskin's advice.
Who am I to...
Who am I to, you know, go against Pliskin?
extreme violence.
I just want to take out the camera.
I feel better without it.
I also don't remember how to get through.
Is it right here?
No.
Can I get a hint?
Why are these bombs always such a pain in my side?
It's right there!
Red pipe.
I was just over there though, but...
Ask fat man.
Wait, what do you mean red pipe?
Red pipe is the hinto.
Minto.
Little minto hinto.
I'm too paranoid about this guy.
Hey, stay down.
Or you'll be staying down forever.
I could take him out and then hide him.
in the box.
The guy will never know.
Well, he'll hear.
He won't.
He will hear.
Red pipe.
This one.
I'm not though.
Wait, do I crawl through here?
I did it.
Beep.
a little lower there we go stinky averted this is riding the
c4 found in strut a has been frozen and disposed how many
more do i have explosives were planted in the pump room on
the first floor yeah crazy this is all wrong this is
something only an amateur would do what do you mean all the
bombs that have been found so far don't appear to be in the
right kind of location Probably.
Even fat man to make mistakes, right?
No, no.
There's something else going on here.
Get a move on with the disposal, right?
I've got a bad feeling about this.
Do you think it's a trap?
I don't know.
But I'm gonna tell Pliskin to watch his back too.
Just hurry.
Wait, where's the next one?
Hold on, Stilman.
Will you consider streaming Unmetal?
I've actually thought about it.
I think I got it.
I don't remember.
But yeah, I would consider streaming it.
No worries asking.
Nebula, thanks for the gifted!
Well done.
It looks like there are no more bombs in that strut.
Now, head for the other struts.
The other struts.
Okay.
Pliskin, what are you doing?
One more bomb diffused.
Me too!
There was one I managed to find only because I took a good
look in first-person view.
You should try it too.
Because I managed to use my eyes.
You should also use your eyes.
Riden.
Use your eyes.
Oh, guy.
Is this guy still... Yeah, we're still good.
Okay.
Let's get out of here.
Go to the next strut.
Good night, little man.
You can see all the darts in his head.
Oh, my God.
like a porcupine by the end oh my god peeing head who you
call him peeing head
who you call him peeing head best acupuncture ever real this
one has some guys don't it
oh oh that's cool it
That's cool and...
Let's not get caught by the...
Wait, is this guy gonna come up and like on this end?
Oh my gosh.
Hi!
Where is he?
Where'd he go?
There he is.
Uh, uh...
Dang it.
I can't shoot it.
I can't shoot it because I'll hear it.
I'm, I think he'll, I think he'll, I think he'll panic.
I should reach if I spray long enough.
The wind will carry it.
The wind will carry it all the way.
No, I can't do it.
It's no good.
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
Oh, come on.
There we go.
And, uh,
uh, can I, oh, come on.
I always...
We were right there.
Oh my god, please!
Shoot!
There we go.
Sometimes that happens to me where I...
try to hit it and it doesn't decide to go.
Rookie mistake.
I know.
Perfect time for some pull-ups.
I'm already...
Oh, you know what?
I think I'll top off my life and we'll grab this.
Let's go look for some more stinky!
What was this?
Oh, oh no.
No, wait, I hate this area!
I hate this area!
Shoot.
what card do I have oh just level one okay oh gosh and I
don't even have I don't even have the nerd here I don't even
have the nerd here I don't even have the nerd here nothing
here nothing here
permission to backseat granted nothing here backseat seating
permission granted?
Is he gonna come back?
I need the nerd.
Uh-huh.
No help.
I didn't ask you!
Actually, what if I...
Hold on.
Backseat tip, don't get spotted.
Oh, this guy's still out.
Completely... Not gonna lie.
I just ran.
out here completely forgot about him i didn't even think
about this guy he was not even on my radar i'm the worst i'm
the worst at sneaking
but they're gonna he's gonna get caught oh my god what the
how did you not get put to sleep now i know the smell is
yeah it's i know where it's at
This room is such a pain.
Oh my god.
This room is such a pain in the neck.
I have to...
Wait, he's gonna say...
They're gonna be like, Hey, why aren't you reporting?
Where's your...
Why aren't you reporting in the room?
Hey, somebody go check it out.
That's what's gonna happen.
Oh gosh.
I hate this room!
I hate this room so much.
They don't see me just aiming my gun everywhere.
right now.
This room.
I hate this room.
Can I take out his, um, but I think I'm going to get, oh,
wait.
I have to take out the other guy.
Oh, gosh.
I wish I took out the other guy because then I could run
around and take out their, um, get their, their radios.
Ah, you can just chaff radio.
Wait, really?
Wait, so if I chaff it while they try to communicate, wait.
You can?
Oh my gosh.
Wait, I gotta get this guy.
Dig in.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
This is good, actually.
Get him.
Get his ass.
There we go.
Okay.
And I'm gonna chaff.
I think that's everybody in here.
Is that everybody in here?
Can I still take out the radios?
Okay.
I don't know that.
Oh, it did.
It did.
It worked.
Just so when the chap is over.
Wait, where is he?
Where'd he go?
What?
Oh, over here, over here.
That's okay.
Ah, shit, shit, shit, shit, shit.
No, no, no.
Chap, chap, chap.
What?
You guys lied to me.
lied to me you guys lied to me you all lied to me you all
lied to me you
i'll never forgive you i'll never ever i'll never forgive
you guys i'll never forgive you i'll never forgive you i'll
never forgive you i'll never forgive you
i need to actually calm down i'm so i'm so mad at you guys
oh my god i'm so mad at you
You guys, I had that room clean.
I had that room clean.
It was so clean and
then...
It was so clean.
Oh, gosh, I was doing so well.
You were doing it right, but the chaff wore off.
No, no.
It was still up.
It was still up while it called.
Oh, I'm so mad.
I'm so mad.
Hold on, I gotta take a walk.
Wait, I was already paused.
I gotta take a walk!
I'm back.
I'm convinced that the Patriots were in my chat and were,
you know.
So it wasn't you guys.
It was the Patriots.
Don't worry.
I believe you.
I'm sorry.
Oh, I'm gonna have to go in there, but for now, we're not
gonna go in there.
Screw that room.
I'm gonna take out this guy up there.
Can I... Oh, wait.
Wrong gun.
Can I hit him from here?
Can I get his tiny little teeny, teeny, teeny head?
What am I...
Whoa!
Sniper Minto added again.
Oh, who's calling me?
Be careful.
There are Claymore mines around there.
Who is this?
Stealth equipped Claymore mines.
Invisible to the naked eye.
Oh.
Identify yourself.
Just call me Deep Throat.
Deep Throat.
You mean from Shadow Moses?
From Shadow Moses!
Mr. X then.
Why would it matter if I called you deep throat?
Never mind about that.
Why did you contact me?
Let's just say I'm one of your fans.
You can't use his line too.
Oh, hello?
Colonel, someone calling himself Mr. X just contacted me.
Call him by his name, right, and it's deep throat.
And whoever it was, it wasn't a burst transmission.
The transmission was sent from within the big shell.
He called himself deep throat at first.
Yeah.
caught that part two but the possibility of it being true is
none it's gray fox no one who used that alias in shadow
moses and he's dead no he's not not in my heart could be
exercise extreme caution extreme caution do i have a mind
detector i don't even have a mind detector oh wait i have
thermal goggles oh gosh oh my god wait i have a question I
actually I don't know if I can trust you guys I have a
question If I crawl Wait it's only in five right that if I
crawl It blows up Oh thank goodness Oh my god my eyes You
know what screw it I'm just gonna crawl I'm not going this
way I go this way Keep going
Wait Okay.
Ah!
My eyes!
Okay, and then there's a bomb in here.
Is this also the room that I hate?
No, I think that's the middle one.
Or is it this one?
A parcel room.
This one...
I think this room was pretty okay.
I don't remember where the bomb...
I know there's two guys.
Right?
It's just the two?
Nothing here.
Where's our status report?
I gotta shoot his butt.
Okay, hold on.
Can you see me?
No.
Once he goes back.
I'm gonna try him.
Get this guy out first.
Oh, oh.
The boxes!
I was too slow.
Oh, shoot.
Um, where is he coming from?
I think he's gonna see me.
He's yawning.
He's stretching.
The other guy's asleep!
Hey, hey.
Freeze.
Oh, my God.
Yippee!
You know what?
I'm not doing this again.
Sorry.
I'm a murderer now.
This is this is me now.
I'm a murderer.
I'm a murderer
Sorry, mister It's done burning You enjoy All the killing is
that a radio?
Or is that just him?
I think he's just got a thick butt Sorry, okay.
Sorry, buddy.
Anyway, time to find a bomb Oh my bad.
Oh Wrong thing, wrong thing.
What?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, I shot the radio!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
I shot the radio!
Maybe they won't come.
Uh-oh.
Enemy personnel on board!
All units, nice and familiar!
Send the replacement guard for the enemy.
I think I'm gonna turn into the Joker.
I think I might actually turn into the Joker.
I think I'm going to turn into the Joker.
I might actually turn into the Joker.
What do you
mean that wasn't the radio?
I thought he just had a fat ass.
That guy never even sent in a status report.
That guy never even lifted his radio even once.
That guy never even gave a two flips about his radio.
And now suddenly you care about the status report.
Why are you telling me this now?
And I'm facing the wall.
Do
you think I'm safe?
I can't see anything.
I think I could get the nerd at least.
There we go.
This game terrifies me.
It's too advanced for my pea brain.
It's too advanced for my pea brain for real.
Oh, goodness gracious.
Wait, did they not...
Did they only replace the one guy?
I think they only replaced the one guy.
Oh.
No, we didn't notice the other one.
You understand how smart you are?
Stay strong, Ghost Mage.
Thank you.
Nothing here.
Wait, I'm scared of taking him out though.
Okay, hold on.
There's somebody there.
No?
Nobody here.
I'm just gonna box it.
Oh, wait.
He's gonna see the other dead guy!
Oh, never mind.
He doesn't care.
These guys!
These guys are ridiculous, I swear.
They're so silly.
I love these Gherlukovich soldiers.
They're so dumb.
Okay, you know what?
I'm just gonna try and find the bomb well nothing
here I want to get that cardboard box though if I shoot his
radio and then will he notice let's go upstairs nothing
where's this lead to hold on I don't want to go out yet I
think he'll hear I find Just take him out.
I'm on the right place, right?
Yeah, there's a bomb in here somewhere.
Ask Pliskin.
What has Pliskin got to say?
That guy's so smart.
Looks like the enemy sentries have the defensive parameters
of each strut covered.
You'll be safe as long as they don't radio for more men.
But if you're spotted, run for it.
Find a good concealment and wait until the backup leaves.
He's so smart!
while you're being chased down believe me he's so smart
smart guy you know what do i go downstairs i can't remember
where it's at come on right in back right in right in
is it downstairs
nothing here no but this is where the... Oh, there's the
mind detector.
No, I can't go through there yet.
And I can't go through there yet.
I guess we go upstairs?
When you know, but you don't want to help.
It's these little things, though.
These details I forget so much, you know.
Wait, um...
No.
I thought I remembered, but I don't.
I thought I remembered.
But I do not.
Nothing here.
I don't remember.
The heliport.
This is another place.
This is...
Wait.
We're not about to experience this part, are we?
Do a Frogbert codec call.
What do you mean by that?
care of that annoying fly what's the situation over there
puzzling i saw a man dressed like a ninja just now hmm ninja
it's the only way to describe it a kind of cyborg ninja
complete with a sword what are you hiding something from me
whoa arsenal tangu don't be a fool think i wouldn't know the
difference i've never seen field gear like that ever all
right trolls anything else actually one more thing you'll
find it hard to believe though i saw a man hiding under a
cardboard box where where it wasn't me it wasn't me so you
believe me this time what the hell is an arsenal tangu
before like i know what a tangu is whoa oh my gosh you must
be one of dead cell of course not what a thing to say
Olga's so eyesaw
Where'd she go?
She did a flip She's so cool
I saw a female soldier Russian must be Olga Gerlukovic How
do you know?
Unlike you, I've been briefed She's not a dead sow No, she
commands a Russian private army they must be the ones
patrolling the big shell what's that right she's led the
group ever since her old man colonel lukovitch died watch
yourself with her she's a tough one yeah what's that
supposed to rain so aggressive oh there are guys here uh
let's have our other gun now Can they see me here?
Whoa, there's two of them.
Where's the other guy?
Hello, hello, hello, hello.
I'm a natural.
Wait, do these guys have radios?
I'm so paranoid.
I'm so paranoid of radios.
I think it usually happens like immediately though, right?
Oh, can I flip you?
Oh, wait.
Is this it?
Oh, that's it.
Is it?
Oh, my bad.
Sorry.
This is it.
No, no, sorry.
My bad.
Sorry.
This is it.
Nope.
Where is the radio?
Is this it?
Oops.
Sorry,
mister.
I was just trying to find a radio.
Sorry.
Um, uh...
I gotta hide the body.
I gotta get rid of the body.
They won't notice, they won't care about the blood.
We gotta get rid of... We gotta throw them into the ocean.
We gotta get rid of the...
I didn't...
I thought...
There has to be a way to flip them over.
I don't know how!
Oh, dang it.
Is there a way to flip them over?
Or...
You know?
Dang, this whole ship is stinky.
I mean, this whole aircraft is stinky.
Oh, whatever.
Um, I probably will have to lay down.
I don't hear anything.
Oh.
This smells like ship.
Oh,
there it is.
Can I reach?
Hold on, let's get in closer.
There we go.
Oh, I can't reach.
Just kidding.
That should be good.
That should reach it.
Perfect!
All right, that takes care of that.
Did you have anything for me?
Woo!
I
think I saw that there's a guy over here.
Right here.
Isn't there?
Yeah.
Let's ignore him and run away.
We don't need to talk to that guy.
We can ignore him and run away.
I could just ignore him.
Yes?
Yeah, I didn't hear the gun.
Do you remember the day we met?
I'm kind of busy right now, Rose.
Yeah!
Keep going.
It was right after I transferred to New York.
There are all these tourists around you in front of the
federal hall.
Oh my gosh, it's starting.
It's starting.
And these ladies came up and asked me which building it was
that King Kong was climbing in the movie.
the chrysler building and then you um actually me started
mouthing off you were like no it's the empire state yeah
dummy dummy stupid woman it's empire state building arguing
and i forgot all about the tourists i was insisting that i
was right and you were doing the same the next thing we knew
the japanese women had gone away yeah because i don't want
to listen to two people bickering to see who had the better
recall we argued all the way to battery park and for nothing
since the museum was closed we went our separate ways from
the museum i love this version of the song coincidence out
in the base corridor an amazing coincidence that we were
actually working at the same place that night we went up to
the top of the empire state it was so beautiful yeah i could
look down on the chrysler building from 120 stories above
ground i felt overwhelmed i didn't care anymore who was
right yeah i would hope not after that much time?
We watched King Kong in your apartment a bunch of times.
Oh, I bet.
Didn't sleep till morning.
Oh.
If it weren't for that coincidence, we wouldn't be together.
I know.
I'm sorry, Jack.
I'm taking up your time again.
What?
Take care.
No, Rose, keep calling me, please.
Please, I eat it up.
Please.
Oh, my gosh jack do you remember the day we first met rose
i'm rose please there are bombs there are literal bombs i am
diffusing i'm i am bomb diffusing right now rose am i wrong
for kind of liking rose jack no they're my favorite couple
ever i love them i love them woman yeah he comes up he just
comes up can you imagine i just imagine her being like hmm
to these like group of like very women they're just like oh
no comment about oh I've killed someone oh Jack it's a
battlefield my opponents are living breathing human beings
this isn't like the VR training they have bodies they have
had lives I took all that away from them but you've got no
choice if you want yeah yeah because of the VR training I
can't help but try and block out that I killed a person it's
the only way I and manage to fight jack i didn't mean to
kill them care what it takes just as long as you come back
the first two yes but not that last guy please just come
back in one piece in one piece um oh yeah i could can you
just imagine like these these ladies are just like oh
sumimasen excuse me do you know which building was king kong
and she's just like hmm i'm pretty sure it was the chrysler
building And I just see his head whipping around.
He's just like,
stupid woman, the Chrysler building.
It is the Empire State Building.
You stupid idiot.
Why would you say it's the Chrysler Building?
When everybody knows it's the Empire State Building.
She's like huffing and puffing.
And she's just like, whoa, man.
She's just like, you don't have to be so rude.
You don't have to be so rude.
And then they're just arguing, walking along, arguing, and
just being so angry at each right stillman is a top-notch
explosives technician follow his orders and disarm the
explosives okay but exactly Colonel why are you being so
boring gotcha oh I'll look him up hold on a moment so your
earlier rant about MGS 5 what are you even talking about
wait wait wait wait it's completely different I was right
everything's going smoothly over here I just finished
defusing me too on an enemy soldier's bed what so the guy
didn't notice sir well done it looks like there are no more
bombs in that strut now head for the other struts King Kong
watch along when we have to watch it over and over and over
again we can't get any sleep you guys just like them just
like my favorite couple is that Is the other guy Did they
replace him or is he just still Dead on the ground over
here?
Oh, he's He's back.
Hold on.
Is he just gone?
They didn't replace him at all?
Nothing here.
I don't think they replaced him.
Back from the dead?
Crazy.
Okay.
I'm trying to decide if I want to head back to this one and
risk it all.
It's kind of annoying because otherwise...
I think this...
Hmm.
Save F for last.
Yeah, I think we'll save it for last.
I'm just trying to decide how I want to do it, but...
Can I get on top of this and, like, go as a box?
I think that's what you can do, right?
Rydan?
Ask for upies.
Wait, I can't go this way, though.
Oh, it's over here.
That's right.
I know.
I know the way.
What's box two?
Oh, is this zone of the Enders one, or...
Oh, no.
I think... Where is this zone of the Enders one?
Have I not gotten to that part yet?
Bye-bye.
Upies from Rydan.
Rant survives a hellish childhood and becomes a functioning
adult who Transplains video trivia to random women on the
street.
Is that a sniper up there?
Yeah, you know, that's just riding things.
Wait, how do I get rid of the sniper?
Go away, stop staring, you freak.
Trying to wait for the other guy.
But he'll notice, won't he?
Oh, I think I have to...
Okay, it's red light, green light.
Green light.
Oh, he's walking away.
Hey!
He gave up!
And now we can take out your friend.
There we go.
But I am still going to put on a box just in case.
Goodbye.
Bye-bye.
Nice.
Stret the...
Oh, wait.
No.
No, no, no, I hate this room.
No, no, I hate this room.
Okay, I was thinking this was the one in the middle.
I hate this room.
I know I slightly remember where it is.
It's on the other side in one of those, like, I have to I
hate this room.
Oh, I hate this room.
Because it's such a pain in the butt.
The nerd, I think, is right underneath me.
But it's knowing when I'm safe to move.
Until then.
Which makes it.
Wait, where's the nerd?
Ah!
He sounds too close.
Where's the nerd?
Ryo,
I don't need you to be a smartass, okay?
Yeah, I know I can drop down, okay?
It's still, you know, if I don't know their patterns, it's
still...
This room is also still very annoying despite that.
And also...
I think that is right there, right?
I still don't know their walking patterns and stuff.
I still can't see them right now.
So...
Come on.
Please.
Okay.
I pressed triangle!
Are you alright?
I love the picture of him just floating in the water.
It's just like a dead fish.
Nothing here.
That was a door.
Okay.
the nerd i cannot i cannot remember where it's at in this
room i don't remember oh this is a psg oh i wasn't paying
attention earlier what was all that grip strength for
whoa where is it and there's so many guys in this room too
again it just becomes so
i can't remember if he does his little walkie thing
Nothing?
Nobody?
Look, he has to go all the way up and around.
I'm just gonna run.
Where's the nerd?
Oh, it's down that!
Oh, it was down there!
I knew it!
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
Back asleep.
And you two.
Damn it.
Oh, I almost got him.
There we go.
But now it's going to be...
Where's your status report?
I'm really needy.
Why aren't you talking to me?
Why aren't you calling me anymore?
Why don't you...
Why don't you message me anymore?
Uh, status report.
Uh, over.
Status report.
Um, over.
Oh, shoot.
Wait.
Uh-oh.
Where is your...
Where's your radio?
No, I don't want to kill again!
Um, just run.
Just run for the nerd.
Run for the nerd.
Let's just speedrun it.
Oh, run for the nerd.
Run for the nerd.
Okay.
Okay, and, uh, sensor.
It's like down over here or up over here?
I think it's somewhere.
Is it this one?
It was down there.
Yeah, I think it's the bottom.
I think it's one below me.
Wait, where do they come in from?
Am I...
I don't trust myself with dropping down, though.
You know what?
YOLO.
Uh, hello, Ryden?
Oh!
There we
go.
Is it this one?
I got it.
There was nothing wrong.
Everything is all right.
This is Ryden.
Disposal of the C4 in Strip D is complete.
Explosives were planted on the maintenance hatch.
Glad I slightly remembered where it was.
This is Pliskin.
Do you read me, Pete?
Pete!
He's giving him nicknames.
Oh, yeah?
I'm listening.
I checked out the bottom of Strut H for you, Pete.
Wait, what's this about?
I asked Pliskin to look around.
Uh-huh.
Knowing Fat Man, I can't shake the feeling that all the
bombs so far were just wrong.
Oh.
So did you find anything?
Yeah, a hell of a lot of seafood was packed into the bottom
of the Strut.
Pete called it right.
Were these distractions?
Mm-hmm.
So all the other ones were dummies?
Dummies!
Oh.
Oh, never mind.
They're real.
But the detonation wouldn't be enough to destroy the entire
shell.
Uh-huh.
But the C4's Pliskan found would inflict serious structural
damage.
That's not the bad news either.
These are sensor proof.
Oh!
What?
New model, I guess.
The ionization sensor can't detect it.
How did you find them then?
The whole thing is sealed tight to prevent vapor leak.
And there's no trace of that Cologne signature.
Uh-oh.
Pete, looks like he fooled you.
No.
Yes.
but you managed to find the thing anyway for sheer luck
bombs that are invisible to the sensor he used R1 hidden R1
you can't move fast enough he's right I can try the spray
from a distance hold on there's something not right about
this one I can feel it well Pete should I come back and get
you no there's no need right you have one left to go correct
yes right except for those scentless ones how about you
Pliskin I have two left not hey pliskin come on pick it up
pick up the pace buddy it'll have to be me i have the level
four card that'll get me into shell two in any case you'll
never make it but that bad leg of yours they'll spot you for
sure that won't happen i i can walk just fine i can even run
what do you mean wait what that bomb five years ago i messed
up even with all my experience i lost it and a church kids
playing nearby to my god these past five years i've lived a
lie lied yes lie i didn't lose my leg in the explosion pete
stilman peter stilman my mistake all i could think about was
hiding from the crime shielding myself from the public
outcry i wanted people to be sorry for me for my weakness
you wanted people to feel sorry for you after people died
the real victims oh my god this is no prosthetic i can keep
my footing on catwalks and hike over deserts oh my god this
guy is peter peter stillman you are ashamed i'm ashamed i'm
what i've killed my soul my plan that hurts it's made my
life even more hellish what good can that do the victims i
know that's not fair i'm a coward that's not better Pete God
forgive me I can walk with my own two feet and I need them
to stop fat man his crimes are also mine one of omission in
arrogance yeah no one should teach the skills I taught him
without a clear conscious this is the only way I can diffuse
my own sins I get you Pete that one's all yours you got it
riding yeah I understand Pete I've taken care of guards and
stretched G and H okay good We won't have to deal with Fat
Man then.
I wouldn't recommend you go into any of the other struts.
I owe you one.
I'll get back to phrasing the baby bombs then.
The baby bombs.
I'm on it.
I'll have the radio with me if you need to get in touch.
Just don't ask for peg-legged Peter.
He's gone for good.
Stopped.
Why would you...
Nobody was going to say that.
Nobody was going to ask for peg-legged Peter, okay?
You weirdo.
my own sins, man.
That's a good question.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
This guy walks away, right?
He walks away, right?
Oh, my God.
Can you not?
I think I can take him from here.
I think the other guy is still asleep, too.
So let's just run for it.
Super baby bombin' method.
Okay.
Am I on the right floor?
Yes.
Hokey-doky!
We made it!
Woo!
Oh, a gate.
Yeah, that's so funny.
So funny that there's a gate here.
Oh, almost.
There we go.
How much?
Okay, I was going to say, how many bullets do I have?
pretty good.
Keep stealing from these guys.
It would be funny if there was like, if you kept stealing
from guys, that they would have no bullets left, you know?
I wish that was.
You know, they think of everything in this game.
Why is me not, why is me stealing their bullets not doing
anything either?
They're pretty good.
Say it again.
They go get more.
I'm gonna blow.
Oh my gosh, I forgot this part is like so close to the guy!
Whoo!
Good thing he's blind.
Nothing here.
Yep.
I came from this way, right?
Why do the terrorists have tranks anyway?
That's also a good question.
Nothing here.
It's just this guy up here, isn't it?
What does he do?
You're not gonna pee on me, are you?
I sure hope there's no one around here that will pee on me.
I'm not asking to get peed on right now, okay?
Ooh!
Did I...
Are the ones that I got before still gone?
I wish I could get this guy.
Oh my god, I can't see where his aim...
Can you walk away?
Is he gonna look back?
Okay.
Alright, I'm gonna go next time.
I'm gonna go next time.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine.
Oh!
I love when they yawn.
It's so cute.
Look at him go.
His little dot, his little dot self.
Walking away.
I love it.
Let's, um...
Please.
Oh, nice!
Thanks for the day gifted!
Alright, guys.
Let's save real quick, because we're about to enter a hell
that I do not wish to endure.
What can I do for you, Jack?
Rose, please get me out of this damn place.
I hate this one.
I hate this place.
I hate it.
I hate this hell.
Get me out of this hell, please.
I can't believe it.
Stillman's prosthetic leg was all a big lie.
I know, what a crazy...
Don't be too hard on him, Rose.
Oh.
But he's got no right to go around pretending he's got a
prosthetic leg.
That's an insult to people who really can't walk.
That hurts.
Everyone's got their own reasons.
Sometimes you've got no choice but to lie.
Are you speaking from experience, Ryden?
I guess it is now.
necessary sometimes.
Rose?
It's nothing.
Well, see ya.
What's up with this guy?
He's so aggressive.
It appears that Fat Man plays bombs within each of the
struts.
Yeah.
Sorry, I keep calling because I don't want to miss anything,
you know.
Don't want to close my eyes.
Don't want to miss a code call.
That's I want to get all the information.
There's a huge load of C4s at the bottom of Strut H that
won't show up on the radar.
The old man's right.
There's got to be the same thing in Shell 1.
Watch your back.
I'm watching.
What else you gotta say, Pliskin?
They have tranks because someone...
I just got a call from Pete.
He made it to Shell 2.
Wow!
Really?
Pliskin.
I'll take good care of Pete.
Don't worry.
Okay.
Someone on staff is a snake found.
boy no seriously call pliskin with the m9 equipped i think
that's a tranquilizer yeah the sound suppressor yeah hit an
enemy with that and it's good night sleep tight the time in
which the tranquilizer i didn't write a nod at that point if
you want to knock somebody out with a single shot aim
carefully for vital spots like the head or heart night sleep
tight i think i've seen this modified gun before yeah it
looks like the same gun used by Solid Snake two years ago.
Following that terrorist incident, similar models were made
and sold among the fans of his exploits.
The fans?
It's me.
I think that's one of them.
That's me.
I'm one of his fans.
M9 modified for tranquilizer bullets.
When the tranquilizer bullets hit a target, the round uses
the force of the impact to mix the drug.
But don't call me Deep Throat.
The pressure of the gas drives a built-in piston that
injects the target with a powerful anesthetic.
It's like firing a small hypodermic I know, I porcupine that
guy.
This M9 is a tranquilizer gun that knocks out the anime.
It doesn't kill them.
Oh.
Little fanboys with the M9.
Colonel, what do you have to say about that?
Ryden, leave the odorless C4 on Strut H to Stilman.
Your job is to dispose of the C4s left on Shell 1.
Locate every last one.
Okay.
I like Ryden's small little...
nod there he's like hmm it's so cute wait i also want to
call him with the box hold on let's call him in the box hey
bliskin bliskin how do you feel about this box the cardboard
box that you have is ideal for fooling your enemies it's
true it's a very important tool for infiltration very
important of course i can't begin to count the number of
agents whose lives were saved by a cardboard box you mean
everyone's using them I'm not exaggerating when I say the
success of your mission hinges on how you use that
cardboard.
It's true, it's true.
Huh.
But in the end, a cardboard box is only made of paper.
Yeah.
Handle it with care or it won't be of much use to you.
You know, I've lost a couple thanks to you.
What?
Nothing.
Forget it.
Treat your cardboard box with care.
Lost a couple of what?
Take care of the box and it'll take care of you.
Don't think of it as just another box.
Because of me?
Treat it with love.
Don't be rough.
okay this is how you know you know what kind of uh
relationship you're going to get into with pliskin he's
gonna treat you with love he won't be rough with you what a
weirdo what are you talking about what are you talking about
oh gosh i don't want to go in here you guys i don't want to
go in I hate this place.
I hate this second room.
I hate this place.
I hate, I hate, I hate Strut F Warehouse.
I hate it.
You can do this.
Okay.
This place sucks.
I don't even I don't remember where the um
doesn't someone come here
I didn't destroy all the radios there was one that I didn't
get Anzi he's even calling I I don't know actually I feel
like it's probably been long enough that the radios are
reset right I have to drop down from the second floor I know
I know I know where to go for the bomb I just don't remember
where the node is
I hate this place Eek Oh
It's over
I forgot he walked over here I'll be honest I
hate this route I hate this route Oh, I hate this.
Oh, I hate this room.
Room!
It sucks so much.
I think that's the guy.
Maybe he's the only one with a radio.
I wonder.
Do you like any room?
I don't mind most of them.
It's really this one that I hate.
Maybe if I just...
Maybe if I just wait it out.
This would have just made me...
or this room or when she's one microsecond late to the
street.
Oh, or us when she's one microsecond.
The status report guide.
If they come to check on the guy and find nothing, they
should stop bothering you.
It's on you if it's worth the hassle.
Wait, what do you mean?
Oh, she's shorter than I expected.
Please follow forwards.
Yes.
Oh, wait.
If I use my gun, they'll hear...
They'll hear it.
You can break the radio with the M9?
You can?
Am I getting one guide right now?
I don't know if I'm getting one...
I have no idea.
I don't think you can.
Because you can't take out the...
You can't take out the...
What's it called with them?
Hide his body where?
I'm not coming.
I'm not getting...
Oh my god.
Nobody.
I'm gonna get caught.
I'm gonna get caught hardcore.
My kids.
Where's the nerd?
Just give me the nerd.
How you just respond?
I broke your thing!
Oh, here it is.
There it is.
I got it.
Yippee!
I broke it, though!
Why?
How are you still calling?
Okay, now I'm gonna go grab his body.
grab his body and run run run and run in here oh my god are
they going to come in here oh they didn't they didn't come
in okay okay okay that was so close there we go and then I'm
going to hide in the box I'm just going to box it I'm just
going to box it I don't know if they'll come in here I don't
know if I have time before they come in.
Okay, okay, okay.
I got another box.
Did they leave?
That's it?
Oh, they did not leave.
They're leaving now.
There they go.
Oh, wait.
Did they just replace him with somebody else?
But this guy doesn't come in here, right?
to get up there
or is that the guy is that the guy on the second floor i
can't remember you know what it's fine no i think that's the
guy i can't tell nothing here it looks like they replaced
them
oh where's the um oh yes here right
Don't forget the vent.
Yeah, I remembered it.
Your little secret title.
But also, you can see it on the...
You can see it pretty easily on the...
Is this the...
Which one is this?
Oh!
Big.
Big news!
Oh, shit.
Oh shoot.
Wait, now if I take out their...
If I take out their bullet or their radios, will they
notice?
If I shoot their behinds?
Oh my god, big, big, big, big news!
Big news!
Where's the...
Is it under here?
Oh.
Yes.
Big news!
Will they notice if I...
If I shoot their little beehives?
HQ will still notice.
No they won't!
That's the point of shooting the...
The radio, isn't it?
Isn't that the point of shooting the radio?
I think this guy is right here.
Lethal mode activated.
I'm waiting for him to walk away.
way.
Nothing here.
Oh, this is a dead end.
Uh, oh my god.
Where the hell am I?
I need to get upstairs.
Nothing here.
How do I get upstairs?
Okay, hold on.
formulating game plan what is that guy upstairs oh okay
there's okay now there's a guy down here okay ah that's why
i'm so okay sorry i was like that's why i'm confused because
there's a guy right there i forget that the upstairs also
has i can't go in here can i Upstairs has, like, a little
hallway as well, you know what I mean?
Where is this guy anyway?
Oh, no, now there's two of them!
Wait, no, I think he's still upstairs.
There's so many guys in this room!
The guy would spot you with a broken radio, then you run
away and you get a caution instead of an alert.
I did know that.
It's the...
If they're out and their radios are broken, then nobody...
nobody ever comes is what i'm trying to say where is this
guy
peep peep are you coming downstairs
oh my goodness just
a box just a box oh my god i'm in his way Why are you
walking against the wall?
Why are you walking against the wall?
No!
Run!
Oh my god.
Damn
it!
Oh, we made it.
We made it.
We made it!
Oh my gosh, no alert.
I made it, baby.
Okay.
I just need to get over to that one area and drop down and
defuse the bomb and we'll be good.
Ish.
And then I have to leave.
Oh, God.
But I have my handy dandy.
Everything.
Oh.
I have my handy dandy.
Okay, this guy comes down, right?
Who's coming?
Someone's gonna come over here.
Maybe not, just kidding.
Oh, oh, who's coming over?
Nope, okay.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, oh.
I'm a coward, you guys, I'm a coward.
Here he comes, here he comes, here he comes.
Here he comes, here he comes.
Don't look, ow.
Oh my gosh.
And then, um, don't notice him.
Don't notice him.
Yes, good, good, good.
And then, oh, shoot.
Uh, you know what?
Oh, no, I didn't mean to do that.
Sorry.
Sorry, friend.
I'm just gonna go once this guy stops looking.
There we go.
Run!
Here.
Here?
Right then.
Flip.
Drop.
In.
There we go.
Okay.
Whoa, just in time, too.
That guy was right there.
I don't care.
I don't care!
I just gave him a little love bite.
That's all.
I have the last C4 frozen.
There's nothing showing up on the sensor now.
Good work, Raiden.
Thank you.
Come on, Pliskin.
Get on my level.
It's a bomb, all right.
It's a bomb.
You think there's another one in Shell 1?
For sure.
Somewhere at the bottom of Strut A.
Why are you so certain?
Yeah, we left them a souvenir.
Yeah, just a little bit of a love bite.
You mean that Shell 2 will actually sink?
Oh, gosh.
Not immediately.
There'll still be five struts left.
Oh, my God.
But if Shell 1 loses a strut at the same time, it'll be a
very...
Oh no!
The big shell structural integrity depends on a very exact
balance.
If both shells lose a strep each, the whole structure will
tear itself under its own weight.
I think, you know, people say solidus did nothing wrong.
I think also fat man did nothing wrong.
It makes combined use of a neutron scintillator and a
hydrogen bomb detector.
You brought that stuff with you?
Of course.
I made the calibrations while I was in the pantry.
I was making nuclear bombs.
I was making hydrogen bombs in the pantry.
He's cooking.
I can do is a sound beacon not the radar sound sound the
shorter the interval between beacons the closer the target I
get you there's another one in that pantry I was in you can
go back and get it it's all yours I'm going to study it some
more and see if the freezing process will work don't touch
the other one until I say so okay okay I'll stand by until
you radio in okay I'm just gonna hide here I'm in like a
perfect spot you guys don't even understand
Nobody is going to find me here.
I'm just going to...
I'm literally...
I'm amongst the boxes.
Nobody can find me here.
Nobody will find me here.
Oh my god, look how fast they go.
Nothing here.
Wait, what do you mean?
Wait, where did he go?
Wait, what?
Where did he go?
I need you to leave, please.
I need you to, like...
Actually, where do I go?
Colonel, what do I do?
Ryden, go pick up the new sensor Stilman told you about.
The one that can detect odorless sea foams.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Head for the kitchen off Strut Sea Missile.
Actually, you know what?
It's probably good that we did this.
one last then and he's now we're like kind of in the we're
kind of um in a good spot like we're not too far away go
pick up that sensor for odorless c4 okay okay okay where you
found pete okay everybody's telling me to go get this smelly
detector right i've ready the sensor that's capable of
detecting odor okay i get it i know in the strut sea pantry
fetch it fetch it i I'm just waiting for this guy right
here.
Then I'm going to make a break for it.
Oh, get up there.
And up there.
Up there.
Ryden, please.
Or is it here?
Actually, I'm not quite sure.
Oh, my God.
You look directly at me!
Okay, we're finally out of the F room.
FU.
FU room.
Where's the guy that's here?
Oh, there he is!
Wait, not the coolant!
Oh.
Oh, come on!
Dang it.
That was close.
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
Wow, wow, wow
We'll get him.
We'll get this guy.
We'll get this little thing.
Oh.
They can do that!
It noticed him!
It noticed him asleep!
Oh my gosh, they're coming this way.
The situation is normal.
All clear.
Uh...
I should have, um...
I should have...
Hmm?
There's somebody there.
Abandon the box!
Abandon box!
I didn't know you could do that.
Do you think they're gone?
Do you think I could go get it again?
Gaming.
That was amazing.
I just unequipped it at like the exact correct time.
No, my box is gone!
Oh well.
Treat it with love.
It treated me with love.
That was true.
I will never game that hard ever again.
I think in my whole afterlife.
I think I will never game harder than I did in that moment.
Wait, was that the orange box?
No, my orange box.
No, the orange.
The orange.
The research.
spawns in the parcel room?
Oh, okay.
Does it?
I hope so.
I mean, there's lots of boxes in there.
Gosh, all these guys having all their stupid radios, doing
all their stupid talking.
Stop talking!
Just everybody, everybody's shot up.
Everybody's always talking so much.
Soldiers these days.
Everybody's, the guy is so needy.
He's just always waiting for...
How are you supposed...
How do you know that one person doesn't call in?
You know, it's just so needy.
So needy.
Okay.
Why are they so competent?
SMH.
That's what I'm saying.
Wait, why am I not?
Oh.
La la la la la la la la la la.
HQ needy.
Oh,
come on!
But, was it this thing that noticed the guy over there?
Like, I thought I saw a little tiny exclamation point come
up.
Or am I... am I crazy?
Oh, there it is.
Oh my god, please.
I can't hit these things ever.
Please!
Ah!
There's a guy here.
Name Doko.
I'm going local.
First try.
Oh, I forgot there's no under here.
How this guy comes in, you know?
Don't mind me, I'm peekaboo.
I'm doing a little peekaboo.
I'm paying tribute to my country.
Where is he?
Oh, he's not over here.
Is there anybody in here?
Hello?
Whoa, it's huge.
Here we go.
Peter, I have sensor B.
I have sensor B.
Strut A.
How's your invisible bomb?
I'm looking at it, but I'm keeping my distance.
How's Pliskin doing?
Yeah, keep your distance.
A few more minutes.
I just got to the last strut, but there are a few enemy
sentries I have to take care of.
Pliskin, you're...
He's probably...
Pliskin's just a novice, though.
I think.
The detonator hasn't been activated.
What?
But the sensors are live, which means...
Which means...
This is Pliskin.
Oh!
I've located the last C4.
Oh, whoa, he's fast.
Is that it?
I'm about to freeze it.
I don't know.
Wait, wait, Pliscan!
Ah!
Damn, that was it.
What's going on?
The detonator just woke up.
It's counting down.
Oh my god!
The big ones were rigged to be activated when all the baby
C4s went offline.
Right.
The one and shell one should be counting down too.
Hurry!
What's the remaining time?
400 seconds.
Oh, 400 seconds.
400 seconds?
Right.
Move.
Get to the bottom of Strut, Amy.
Now!
400 seconds!
Yeah!
I'm gonna save real quick.
Jack, you okay?
Girl, I don't think so.
Is she gonna talk to me?
400 seconds!
Baby C4s, ooh.
Baby C4s, baby babies!
Hang in there.
Thank you.
Okay, so where am I going?
Uh, strut A?
Oh, geez!
Ah!
Just run for it, Ryden!
Run for it!
Oh, that's the door.
Run, run, run!
Run for it, Ryden!
They're dumb, they're stupid.
B.
Boy, boy, boy, boy, boy.
Boy.
Eh?
Which way is it?
Oh yeah.
That's where I came from before, right?
Oh yeah, that's right, that's right, it's this room.
Everybody's still asleep.
It's so good.
It's nice.
I was like, I saw the guy on the radar and that's why I was
confused.
Um.
Bum, bum.
Oh, shoot.
I always...
Ow.
We don't have time to deal with you guys.
Come on, come on.
Pick up the pace.
We're all going down.
I mean, I have time to, like, grab a snack, though.
I think.
Oh.
He actually left me a snack.
Yay!
Go!
We don't have time!
Hey!
Wait, so where do I need to go?
To the bottom.
How do I get to the bottom?
Oh, I go upstairs, right?
And then...
I go upstairs to go downstairs.
I think?
Is this PS2, PS3, or Master Collection?
This is PS2.
Um.
I think I'm just gonna go for it.
There we go.
Right.
Bliskin.
Listen carefully.
What is it?
I fell for it.
Oh, fell for what?
Her?
Fat man has my number.
Fat man?
A proxy.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Microwave?
Hallway?
What?
It's not a technique I told him.
Neither was that multi-bomb booby trap.
Looks like he's far surpassed me as far as explosives
technique goes.
As for the rest?
Pete, get the hell out of there!
Get the hell out of there!
What?
Wait, I didn't take that long!
You told me to go to A.
Keep your distance.
No.
Use the spray.
from as far away as possible okay me you can do it me i'm
not so sure you got this riding do it i know you can pete
pete i'm not sure how i feel about that
sorry let's Oh my god, sorry, sorry.
I don't know how I feel about that.
I have a feeling we might be fighting someone in there.
We're going all the way back to where we started.
Uh, is it in here?
I can't remember where it's at.
Please, a man just died.
Where was it?
No.
Hold on, I'm looking.
Oh, maybe I go through over here.
Is it over this way?
Yeah, we got tons of time.
I think we're good.
And you were laughing.
Did you hear what he's...
It wasn't me, it was riding.
Isn't it?
It's not in the water, right?
There.
Yeah, I was right.
I don't know how I feel about that.
Oh, no.
Is it this one?
200 seconds!
Yeah!
Come on.
Isn't it in the locker?
That literally turned...
I was like, no.
You cannot be even...
You cannot be any colder.
I thought I was...
I know you guys, I don't remember where that...
Why can't it be smelly instead?
Um, I'm gonna check the water.
I don't think it would...
How would I use this coolant in the water though?
How do I die?
Oh, go down.
Shoot, I don't remember how to...
Oh, there we go.
Oh, I'm so close!
It's like right here!
I'm like so close.
Guys, I don't think it's the water.
Oh.
Sometimes you have to look in first person view.
Stillman, can I get a hint?
Oh, wait.
Bliskin!
Colonel, Stillman is dead.
I know.
She has not played this game before.
I can't remember the bomb locations.
I only remembered the one.
The one that was in the pool room.
That was the only one I remembered.
I won't let you die.
All right, then.
Is sensor B equipped?
Yes.
See if it responds or not.
Jack, no matter what, you have to bring an end to this
crisis.
Thanks, Rose.
Oh.
And down.
And round.
Guys, I don't remember at all.
Where the hell is mom?
Is that it?
Wait, is that it?
Blind mint.
Want a hint?
Yeah.
Maybe.
Oh my gosh.
I'm trapped in this little tiny spot.
Wait.
Ah!
I see it.
How do I get to there, though?
Rided.
Oh, shoot.
We actually only have 60 seconds.
Raiden, Raiden, please.
Raiden, Raiden, it's not time to play Fishies anymore.
Or we'll be swimming with the Fishies.
Come on, Raiden.
Raiden, Raiden.
Spray!
Yeah!
Oh!
Colonel, I've neutralized the bomb.
Good work, Raiden.
Thank you!
That was a great loss for everyone.
200 seconds, plenty of time!
Any damage report on the explosion?
Seems that the duct for diverting the contaminated seawater
was destroyed and the central section of shell 2 is
flooding.
Oh my god, no The explosions ignited the oil stick on the
surface.
No, what about the toxins the chemicals stayed in
containment.
Okay There's no immediate danger is the big shell stable
every MGS fan would be very proud of you meant But the
threat of the bomb I don't know why I couldn't remember any
of the places for the bombs Rescue the president get back to
the upper level.
Roger that Oh yeah, the president.
I forgot about the president since we were so focused on the
bombs.
Okay, I hope I don't get ambushed down here.
That would be pretty bad.
What can I do for you, Jack?
Just saving.
President, who?
They could never.
They could never ambush me down here.
Yeah, they won't do that.
They won't do that.
do that hang in there thanks Rose please tell me everything
right I mean I mean Pliskin what are you doing I'm so used
to just saying Raiden Raiden hello
Rose right the terrorists have retaliated for our bomb
neutralization wait what do you mean what a hostage has been
killed Shot in the head they shot one of them on the roof
just to make sure we caught it one of our satellites caught
it clear as day Oh my god.
They announced they would kill one every hour from now on.
That's not fair.
What are my orders?
What should I do stay with your mission objective?
Rescue the president someone got shot and he goes that hurts
President Johnson is your first president Johnson priority
my but they're all in danger.
Yeah, be reasonable I know what you're feeling, but you
can't save them all No, not by myself.
Are you expecting that Pliskin to come through?
Well, looks like he's turned his radio off to.
I can't complete this mission by myself.
That man was not included in the simulation.
He is not a factor in this mission.
What do you mean by that, Colonel?
Yeah, what do you mean by that, Colonel?
Your mission must remain a solo effort.
What about the seals?
No second attempt.
What do you mean by that?
They haven't even gotten to planning that.
All we can do is wait.
In the meantime, You're our only hope.
I understand.
Raiden, go and rescue the president.
You can start off by getting to the upper level of Strut A.
Yeah.
Strut A.
You guys have to go to the bathroom.
I think this might be a good time to go.
Let's take a potty break real quick.
Let's do a quick potty break.
And then, um, we'll go up.
I think right here, right before I go into the next room is
a good spot.
I gotta go to the little ghosties room Body break for
everybody Stretch, get some water
And go to the bathroom I don't want to pee P buff right now
I know going to the bathroom will be a debuff for me But You
know, just gotta do what I gotta do I really gotta go Okay,
I'll be right back
I'm back Oh my gosh, you guys
Matara's out here trying to be like she's some Metal Gear
expert Girl, get past literally two games
She's on Twitter Someone was just like There were games
before Metal Gear Solid And she's just like Yeah, but
they're old and janky I got recommended to do solids if
you're really And then if you really love them Dive into
Metal Gear 1 and 2 I'm like, how dare you say that about
running man I love that guy.
He's not old and janky.
How dare you say that?
Do you have a good pee?
Yeah, I saw that tweet and I was like, Running Man!
I love Running Man.
How could you say that about him?
She's just like...
I like how someone's like, this isn't mint?
What's going on here?
Mint has Mata's Twitter details Mata, I feel your
girlfriend's tastes are rubbing off on you Whoa, whoa, whoa
Let's not Let's not Let's not jump to any Titles now Any,
you know
How dare you say that about Running Man Running Man's the
best Yeah Girl, friend with a space.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
We are girls, we are friends.
Well, kind of.
Even that needs, like, a little bit of a...
I don't know.
Even that needs a bit of a...
An asterisk, you know.
Cliff, or a footnote, I believe.
Anyway, let's get going.
Meow, meow, meow, meow.
that's my ride oh oh oh oh oh oh oh yeah delivery oh my gosh
we get a hot lady delivery i don't remember i think you just
wait this fight out right i don't remember exactly look at
all them bugs
I can't tell you how happy I am that you will arrive at it
all.
I knew this moment would come.
Show yourself and finish me.
You obsessed with me or something?
Like you finished off my father.
Hey!
What?
Otherwise, you'll be the one to die.
Oh, crap.
It's just Ryden's slightly new.
nasal voice that just makes him sound so nerdy.
Oh, cramp.
This could be interesting.
You've seen the fires of hell, haven't you?
Ooh.
Oh.
Hey, that's my ride.
Maybe you can give me death.
My name is Fortune.
Lucky in war and nothing else.
Fortune.
And without a death to call my own.
Hurry.
Kill me, please.
She's so awesome.
Oh my gosh, wait.
Wait.
Oh my god.
This is our first time here in Yadels, Dead Cell!
Yubi!
Why
are you on fire?
I just have to wait this one out, don't I?
Oh my god.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, oh, oh my god.
Oh, my god.
Oh, my
god.
Oh, my god.
I can't see anything.
I can't see where she's aiming at.
Oh, oh my god.
I don't know how long I need to last for.
Go on.
Oh, right in.
Oh.
Oh no!
My box!
Woo!
Oh!
Ah!
Don't get on fire.
Oh my god, no.
Oh my god, Riden!
Oh god, Riden!
Nice save, nice save.
Yeah, let's call it Kodak.
What is she, a witch?
For some reason, I can't hit her.
I can't hit her!
I don't understand.
She's obviously impervious to attack.
What are my options?
Disengage her and get out.
Okay.
The elevator is still upstairs.
Oh.
My retreats came back down.
Hang on until the elevator comes down again.
Your weapons can't hurt her.
And you need to stay alive.
Use whatever cover you can find and invade her.
Evade her.
I wish I could lead her to, like, come over here.
Pliskin!
No!
Oh my gosh.
Oh, my not on fire.
Good for it.
Um, now's not the time, Cardo!
She's right in front of me!
She's right in front of me, isn't she?
What?
He's killed off Peter.
Now he's after you!
How should I know?
Look, this is really not a good time for this.
Oh, seven frames.
I know, right?
Great.
How much time do I have left?
I'll show you the count.
Oh my god.
So he's planning on taking this place out.
It looks like he has a different agenda from that of dead
set.
I have to go all the way back over there.
So annoying.
There's no time.
Which type of explosives is it?
He didn't say.
Ah!
Oh.
Perfect timing, actually.
Oh!
No bisexual!
No, keep playing the theme.
That is not where you ended up, Ryden.
I'll take over, Queen.
What is it?
It seems our friend Fat Man is out of control.
He'll actually try to destroy this place.
Yes, this could unravel everything we've planned.
But why would he do such a thing?
He knows, but he's nothing more than a stereotypical mad
bomber now.
Fat Man did nothing wrong.
We lost sight of our ideals, and with it is loyalty to
command.
She's so awesome.
I expected more of this one, really.
But he couldn't kill you, I see.
Completely useless.
Hey, I'm right here, you know.
I can still hear you.
Later.
Then.
Yeah.
Come on.
Yes, queen.
Now!
Nice one, Riot, and nice one!
Yeah, baby!
Ah!
Now!
Oh, crap.
She's so cool.
She's like, not even you can kill me.
kill me after my lover's been killed.
Raiden is a toad.
What do you mean by that?
Fortunately, he got shot in the head!
No, that death was meant for me.
Why am I the only one who can't die?
Alone again?
Cheated out of death again?
how much will you force me to live how much longer dad
you've punished me enough
just just walk just oh Ryden come on read the rule you could
give me peace Ryden read the room come on man just like you
ever just but you couldn't kill me No.
Just get out of here.
Yeah, just go.
Just come on.
There we go.
Cookie-y-noy.
Cookie-yoy.
All righty.
We gotta get all the way over there in 400 seconds, baby.
He's still alive.
I died once already.
I can't die twice.
You know what that meme is just like killing postponed?
That's him.
How is he alive?
Come on, vamp.
a 400 seconds to the heliport.
Ryden has terrible luck with women.
It's true.
Okay.
Colonel, where's the heliport?
The clock is ticking, Ryden.
Get to the heliport on the roof of Strut E.
I'm the one that had the stinky plane.
Oh, bomb!
Wait, why can't I go over to that one?
Hello?
There we go.
There it is!
BAM!
Okay.
We just gotta go through the hell, through hell, um, hell F.
We just gotta go through F.
I just gotta run for it.
for bomb.
Ah!
Rude!
Fat man!
Oh god.
I know I don't have that much time.
But um, maybe I can find a snack.
No?
It's like the guards left and they were just like, yeah,
this will take care of it.
Oh wait.
That should be on the other side.
Hold on.
Let's go to the other side.
We call them fluffy people now.
Okay.
Is she already...
Oh.
I saw that.
Does she already defeat Batman?
On my way to do so.
On my way.
Wait a second.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Wait, this is new.
Wait, they're not supposed to be here?
Why are there more guys here now?
Wait, huh?
What the hell?
Wait, why are there more guys here now?
You're not supposed to be here?
Oh, shoot.
Oh, what?
There we go.
Crisis of Arden.
Anyway, let's go.
Let's go!
That was a close one, wasn't it?
Anyone else here?
Nothing here.
I think I should go from up top.
I'm not gonna lie.
Nice.
Nothing here.
I'm just gonna take them out and go.
Oh.
No, don't.
There.
Oh, shoot.
The beep.
Clean.
A little, a little, a little, a little, a little struggle.
Almost triggered the Endless Guard, I know.
Oh, he is up there.
I was going to say, I don't see the guy up there.
Hey, that's where Fat Man is.
That's his spot.
Why are you up there with him?
Just grabbing them real quick so I don't forget.
About them later.
Lucky!
Get all them birds.
Upsie daisy.
Alright, here we go.
Look at all those chickens.
Let's save real quick.
Not that I really need to, I think.
Jack?
Yeah.
Rose, please.
My code name.
Rose.
Rose, please.
Everybody's gonna know my name is Jack, please.
I like Fat Man's fight, though.
I think it's kind of fun.
Be careful, Jack.
Thank you.
Oh.
Oh, there he is.
I think we're okay, maybe.
Actually, I'm just going to box it.
I need to get my old box back.
I need to get my box back.
Box one.
Box one, where are you?
Maybe it's in the next one.
She doesn't need his code name.
Well, she needs his frame to remember what's special about
the date.
Here we go!
Ah, there it is!
Easy peasy!
Right there in the middle.
Hold on, we got time.
We have time to explore a little bit.
Right there.
It totally doesn't look like a trap or anything.
Not at all, not at all, not at all.
Looks totally not suspicious.
Nah.
Sensor A.
Stinky.
Stinkiest area.
Say goodnight, Stank.
Fabriz!
see how close he can get to one second what was my time
oh my god i am fat man i am the greatest that humanity has
to offer you were briefed on this right then hear this
rhythm it's the rhythm of time and life I love Batman.
I love Batman.
He's such a freak.
He's so eccentric.
I love him.
Yeah!
Life is short.
Bombs tell the time with every moment of their existence and
nothing else announces its own end with such a fanfare.
Glad you could make it.
This little straw.
Oh, yeah.
Good year.
Let's drink the stillman, shall we?
If you destroy the big shell, you'll never collect your
ransom.
They don't care about that.
What are you talking about?
Thirty billion dollars in cash.
Just laugh.
So that's what's going on, huh?
What the hell are you talking about?
Oh.
Oh, you'll know soon enough.
And I could care less what they planned to do.
My ambitions are much more simple.
To be the most famous bomber of them all.
You're nuts.
No one's gonna give a damn about you.
Oh, yes, they will.
I'll go down in history.
As the man who beat Peter Stilman, that's the only reason I
assisted them.
Like hell you beat Stilman.
He had your number.
What did you say?
You have nothing of his courage.
I keep talking over each other.
It's so funny.
That croc died of dishonorable death six months ago.
The liquidation of dead cell.
Call it what you want.
Only the right stuff survive that hell.
Set me free, you know.
Open the way to a new dimension.
Dimension.
So that I can become the emperor among detonation devotees.
You're nothing but a common criminal and that's the only way
people will ever remember oh dear you i'm an ox a new
dimension that is why i dislike boorish military types it's
time to start the party yeah the party this is how it works
i plant a bomb yeah and it'll explode soon after that okay
if you prefer to stay in one piece you'll have to decide
laugh and grow fat yeah He said the thing!
Laugh and grow fat!
Oh shoot.
Hey don't shoot me man, don't shoot me.
I'm not ready yet.
Hey hey hey hey.
Is that all of them?
Hey hey I saw that.
Hey I did- I literally just disarm the other two oh my god I
just disarm the other two come on okay oh I got to get his
head there we go
whoa where is it don't shoot the birds man The way he falls.
I was wondering if I should do a...
Oh, oh.
A, uh...
Oh my
god, what's the word?
Pacifist run, I guess?
With the tranquilizer, but...
I think it's okay.
Oh my god.
Maybe I should use auto-aim.
Oh.
Are you gonna plan anymore or are you done?
Oh,
are you okay?
Are you okay, man?
Are you a clown?
Oh, one.
I got it.
More bombs.
You asked for it.
Where do you put the other one?
Oh, all right.
Wait, where is it?
That's the one I disarmed before.
It's not underneath, is it?
I'm right here, dummy.
Wait, where is it?
It's not this one.
Right?
This is the one I disarmed before.
Is this it?
Again?
Oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god!
Oh, here it is!
Hey, where'd you go?
My bad.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
Calm down.
There we go.
He's aggroed!
Oh, I need to reload.
Does that reload again?
Like in the original?
Unequipping and re-equipping?
I don't think it does, right?
Oh,
it dies?
Where is he?
Whoa!
Ouchie!
Ouch, ouchie!
Oh, it dies, nice.
Oh!
Come back then.
Thank you.
This fight's actually pretty fun.
Oh, oh, oh, woohoo!
Because it's like a...
More bombs!
Oh, come on, right in.
Get his head.
Uh, get his head.
Oh, he's right there.
Ah!
More bombs!
One?
Oh, one.
Here.
Two.
I know.
I'm getting on it.
He's watching me defuse it.
I'm doing it!
Oh my god.
I did your bombs.
Come on, Batman.
Where are you?
Come over this way.
There you go.
Where'd you go?
That was so close.
I don't know where he is.
Just shoot.
Shoot Ryden!
Just shoot Ryden!
Oh my god, he's doing sick...
He's doing sick flips and stuff.
He's doing tricks and stuff.
Oh, I gotta reload.
Hold on.
There we go.
Yeah!
Don't come after me!
Don't come after me like that.
It's spooky.
Oh!
Oh shoot.
He's so everywhere.
Yeah.
Oh, I'm also got to reload.
You're so fast.
I'm just gonna do that for now.
Just so we have, you know, a little bit of...
A little bit of buffer.
That's right.
That's what I thought.
Oh.
There we go.
Reload.
Where'd you go?
Idiot.
Uh.
There we go.
Oh my god.
Please.
There we go.
When are we getting more bombs, Batman?
More bombs!
This time for more bombs!
When are we getting more bombs, Batman?
Oh, whoa!
Where are you?
I just need one more time getting him down.
There we go.
Aw, we didn't get more bombs.
First try, yeah.
This one's not so bad.
honestly because he's so like all over he's like there's an
aggro all the time all right oh no it's just the one it's
just wine it's just the one the party the party the party's
over for you that's what you think what do you mean oh
what's that no nothing to wear to the party.
I don't know.
I have beautiful hands.
Yeah, he does.
These delicate hands can craft work so far.
He puts on so much moisturizer on these hands.
Brian didn't grab his hands.
Feel how soft they are.
It's the switch for the biggest bomb of the entire place.
I've always wanted to hold fat man's hands.
No use.
Once it's activated, there's no stopping the count.
Where did you plant it?
Where is it?
Somewhere in this area.
Don't worry.
It's very close by.
Right to where I can see ya.
Where is it?
Go ahead, shoot me.
I'm already dead.
No!
Think you can find it?
When it goes off, it'll take the big shell with it.
Oh my god.
Tell me where I can find the bomb.
That's your problem.
Die.
Dies.
Bring it on, I say.
they'll be happy too i die here and start my legend too bad
you won't be around to see the movies no laugh and grow fat
yeah fat man laugh and grow fat uh come there buddy come on
fat man Where's the bomb, Fat Man?
Getting the Peter Stillman is so messed up.
Getting the Peter Stillman...
You're a monster.
Thank you!
Thanks to the puns agreement.
Batman is one of my favorite boss fights.
He's like, Evoken Raven and Running Man had a weird baby.
It's true!
Um...
What?
Oh, I'm facing the wrong way.
It's like, where'd it go?
Anyway, um, that was easy.
Good work, Raiden.
Looks like all the bombs are neutralized.
Where's the bomb, Fat Man?
Moves him.
Colonel, Fat Man didn't seem to know about the ransom
demands.
Yeah, how curious.
Intentionally kept in the dark, I'd say.
He seemed to be coming from a very different place from the
other terrorists.
Hmm.
Raiden, a lot of hostages, our president included, are still
in danger.
Keep your mind focused on protecting them.
Johnson!
What are my orders?
We have no idea where he is.
You haven't been in the Central Corps yet.
I suggest you start there.
What are my orders?
Wait.
I have another call.
Want me to take it?
Yeah.
Oh, no.
Best to keep our presence unknown.
Okay.
Hello, Mushy Mushy!
How you doing, kid?
Pliskin, is everything alright?
I just killed Batman.
looks like i was out cold for a while how did you manage to
stay alive had a little help from a friend oh friend what
about the bomb diffused and fat man too that's good news how
shell too it's a mess the bomb crippled h-stress skin is
just taking all sorts of naps isn't he what if the big shell
blows up the explosion is expected to produce massive
amounts of toxins never heard anything about that huh huh
well looks like there's not much danger of that in any case
but the The central core is starting to flood.
It won't last much longer.
What about the president and the other hostages?
No.
They weren't in shell two.
They must be in shell one.
Oh.
We need to get the hostages out of here now.
It's too far from Manhattan for a swim.
What about the lifeboats?
There doesn't seem to be any.
What?
It doesn't make sense.
That doesn't seem up to code.
Right.
And it comes with a pass and be right.
Welcome to Mambusha play.
Thank you.
There are about 30 hostages.
They take more than a single trip.
Can you pilot a chopper?
A chopper?
But I brought a gear head with me.
He's a good guy.
I'll introduce you later.
Pliskin, I'm on the Heliport right now.
What are we gonna be?
Oh no, the Harrier!
Our chances with the Harrier after us are close to nothing.
True.
Do you know where the President is?
No.
That one's all yours.
The President is at the top of our rescue list.
These are our orders, Lieutenant J.G.
J.G.
Your orders.
Not mine.
What?
Your orders, not mine.
Oh.
Five men.
Your orders, not mine.
Oh, he's heavy.
Oh, my God.
I can only carry him for a little bit.
Five.
Oh, I can barely carry him for so long.
Come on, five men.
Come on.
Here we go.
Oopsie daisy.
He's ragdolling him around.
Where's his hands can I take his skates?
Look at them hands Can I take his rollerblades Good night
sweet prince
What else is around here Any snacks not that I really need
any We handled that pretty easily.
Any bullets?
Softly quiet.
Ryden's glutes are for show.
Not moving big weight, I guess.
I know, right?
This guy is such a skinny weenie.
Ah!
I fell in my chair.
Hold on.
The calm before the storm.
Oh my god, it's a ninja!
Oh my god, it's an actual ninja.
Gray fox!
I'm like you, I have no names.
I have...
Are you Mr. X?
Hmm, if you like.
What was that?
But come, let's get out of the open.
Follow me.
That's just, uh, I mean, that...
Mr. X has an accent.
Neither Elmi nor friend.
Gray Fox!
Just a messenger from the Lali Lululelo.
Lali Lululelo?
So, I'm so sorry.
This is safer, I think.
Safe from what?
He's dropping, of course.
All right.
Why did you contact me?
I've been ordered to give you backup No No Ordered by whom
Ordered by whom Speak Why won't you identify yourself?
There is no need to be known I'll decide whether I need to
know You are not yet trusted to make such decisions What do
you mean by that?
I'll tell you something you do need to know instead The
current location of the president Oh, what?
I'll take that Or rather, the person who knows the current
location of the president Who is it?
agent named Ames.
Ames.
Secret service, huh?
Okay.
I'll be honest, the first time I played this, I did not
notice the accent even a little bit.
I did not notice their accent even a tiny bit.
There's no reason for me to believe any of this.
You understand that?
Of course, but you also have no choice.
I think I was just so like, oh my gosh, Grey Fox.
the woods where are those hostages you must be Ames oh oh my
gosh the hostages are being held in the B1 conference hall
in the shell one core you'll find Ames there what does he
look like we don't know if it is indeed a he oh I've never
met this person either oh how am I supposed to look for
someone without even a description I like how they're just
like um hello that could be a woman Ames has a be able to
hear the machine sound in the heart.
Ah.
Do you expect me to walk up to these hostages and listen to
every one of their heartbeats?
Yep.
The sound is too minute to detect on amplified.
You'd be captured immediately.
So what am I supposed to do?
Use the directional microphone.
There's one somewhere in the core.
Oh, in the core.
Okay, we gotta go find, okay.
Get the microphone, get to AIMS, get to the president.
Easy peasy, we got this.
Take this.
What's that?
The security guard will unlock all level two systems.
Level two!
It's called a Pancard.
It works together with your body's only electronic field.
Yeah, I have one.
Nice, but...
Mm-mm-mm.
Okay, what do you want me to do?
Try this instead.
One of the terrorists?
You want me to dress up like one of them?
The surveillance camera won't lay you on the elevator
without the right uniform ah oh my gosh yay we'll be
undetectable oh
oh dang not everybody has the same outfits why doesn't
everybody have the same outfit but i saw them carrying an an
an94 yeah all men assigned to the core section carry a case
oh my god a case so without an ak-74 you someone will see
through me really quickly Hey, hey, he's getting scared over
flies.
You'll also have to pass a retinal scan to get into the
conference.
Ah, not the retinal scan.
Biometrics.
Crap.
Oh, crap.
Deception is not an option here.
Okay.
Oh, crap.
I suggest you hurry.
They have a nuke on their side.
I'm taking their eyes.
They have a nuclear weapon with them?
You didn't find their continuing presence here in the
future.
Even with the president as hostage, this is an island, and
they have no visible means of escape.
Wow.
Even if they do have a nuke, the warhead is no good without
an access code.
The security lockout can't be bypassed.
They don't need to.
They have to take it.
What?
How are you?
You saw it too, I believe.
The Navy man would have a handcuff.
Yeah?
Him, yeah.
That guy who's dead.
The other half of it is on the football or the black case if
you like.
Oh, no.
The football.
And now they have it.
No.
How did they open it?
That guy had one job.
Why did they have to bring the football along to a
decontamination plant of all places?
But they did have to.
Because, after all, the big shell is the farthest thing from
a cleanup plant there is.
What?
dead cell didn't have to bring a nuke along with them it was
right here to begin with maybe nothing in this affair is
what it seems a cover-up but why for what the government
wouldn't wouldn't do a cover-up metal gear
what metal gear but metal gear the very same why they're
only capable of shadow moses even free this is the rt center
for its newest incarnation oh my god what the hell the last
games the rest okay low-key welcome the membership thank you
battle gear what's this for you might be glad you have it oh
my god a cell phone vibration function on oh okay i have my
controller's vibration what do i need a cell phone for oh
ryden's little gasp there
Yeah.
Who the hell was that?
Who was that man just now?
Yeah.
He's not one of ours.
No.
We have no one like that in our unit.
Yeah.
Who the hell was that?
He said that the big shell was housing a new model of Metal
Gear.
First I've heard of it.
Colonel, what are you not telling me?
I've been completely open with you, Raiden.
I don't know.
I told you everything.
Colonel!
Is that everything you know or everything I need to know?
Oh, I forgot you can zoom in.
Snap out of it, Raiden.
I don't know.
I'll have the metal gear rumor looked into you need to make
contact with this aims so you believe that ninja since we
have no leads on the president's current location we have no
other alternatives right now collect as much data as you can
including anything on metal gear those my orders yes they
are disguise yourself as an enemy soldier and infiltrate the
shell one core understood okay
And hence...
You believe that ninja but not Pliskin?
What if Pliskin is the ninja?
Pliskin, do you read me?
He took over for Grey Fox.
I just ran into a guy decked out like a ninja.
A ninja?
Yeah.
Do you know anything about this?
Was it you?
Can you trust that costumed freak?
Oh, it's definitely him.
But the Colonel told me to follow the guy's instructions.
like a good soldier you'll do it right i'll let you in on a
little secret kid the ninja that was publicized in the
shadow moses incident no longer exists the guy you met has
no connection whatsoever with the incident and how do you
know that because i do just be careful who you trust okay
i'm not sure how i feel about that
colonel you have some spleen to do right make contact with
aims and find out where the president is okay our
information indicates that ames is being held in the b1
level of shell one's core okay for the core of shell one
head for the core of shell one's core has extremely tight
security yeah impersonate an enemy personnel to infiltrate
the section for a proper disguise select the enemy field
uniform you receive from the ninja this will allow you to
blend in okay but you still need one more thing the gun it
will look suspicious if you're not carrying the standard
core are equipped with ak-74 use select your own ak when
you're in disguise find yourself and i feel like every i
feel like i've learned i'm hearing more and more of these
like what's that supposed to mean what's that supposed to
mean that i've never heard before these are so funny that's
wrong brian is such a little baby i love him so much that's
wrong Okay!
We gotta go to the core.
Which let's just, um...
There's that guy right there.
Does he look this way?
I don't remember.
Let's just run for it.
Ah!
Alright.
Let's go into the core!
Like a good soldier, save farmers!
Oh wait!
Anybody here?
Nothing here.
Oh wait, not sensory.
Mind D.
Um.
Oh my gosh, there is something over there.
Oh my god!
Wait, where did it, where did that, where did that come
from?
Aye aye.
Oh.
Oh my gosh, please.
Ah!
Really?!
Oh my gosh.
These little bastards.
Oh.
Come on!
Kill it!
There we go.
And one more.
I hate these guys!
Low ammo?
No!
Reload, Raiden.
Oh, wait.
Is that all I have left?
There's no way.
Oh, shoot.
How do I have such few left?
Oh, gosh.
I have to be really careful then.
How am I not hitting it, though?
Um.
Fat Man, I hit them all.
No!
You guys, I think I'm in trouble.
Chaff?
You're so right.
Thank you.
I forgot I could use the chaff on these.
Where is my chaff?
Peep, peep, peep, peep.
And here I gotta run for it.
Because they all...
Yeah!
Woo!
More guns!
No!
I need the eye guy first!
I need AK first.
Where's my outfit?
There it is.
Okay, looking fancy.
There we go.
Oh, strut up for the AK!
Oh shoot, you're right.
Oh!
One second!
Got a minute, Jack?
No!
I don't!
I found some information on where Solid Snake is in great
shoot I've located the gravesite oh and the body the body
zoomed for DNA testing well okay you have the results yeah
the right arm was missing but there was no doubt that it was
him that body belongs to solid snake why was his arm missing
so the head of the terrorist group must be an imposter an
imposter well you sound disappointed when the snake is such
I guess I was kind of hoping to meet the legend in the flesh
I get you but it looks like he's not behind Yay!
The president needs you, I think.
What the heck do you think you are?
Disguise yourself as enemy personnel and infiltrate the core
section.
Your priority is to contact Agent Ames.
Agent Ames.
Okay, I gotta leave.
Dang it.
I forgot that I needed to get the AK.
Where?
What's... Okay, we have...
Key card two.
Whoa!
Look at all them birds.
Oh my god.
We have that guy up there.
I'll take him out.
Came for the old and janky, stayed for the cute ghost.
Yes.
How?
Okay.
Where is the best place to shoot these things?
Because I feel like I'm all...
It's the little gun down here, right?
I'm gonna run out of bullets at this rate.
Ah!
It's lower?
The gun is one shot kill, but it's fin- Yeah, I know!
It's, like, hard.
Now they're all here.
These little... I hate these guys.
I'm gonna have to chaff again, clearly, but I just wanted to
see how to get through them.
I'm wondering if I should just...
Okay.
Wait.
How do I...
Oh, gosh.
I didn't realize how far it was.
What's going on?
Right.
Aim for the top of the site, not the tip.
Okay, okay.
I'll try again.
Or rather, I'm not going to try right now, but I will try.
Okay.
How do I get through this?
Oh, I think on the other side.
Okay, I know how to get through this.
Phew!
Oh my god!
Right, is something wrong?
Right.
Right!
Oh,
maybe I should just reload.
Nah, it's okay.
Okay.
All right, right then.
Nice, nice, nice.
And now grip.
Time to grip, buddy.
We got that level two grip.
Oh yeah, we got that level two grip, baby.
We got that level 2 grip.
We're gonna keep going and we're not gonna stop.
Oh, wait.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
The...
Oh, gosh.
Wait.
The chaff is going down way faster than I thought it would.
Wait, wait, wait.
We're riding.
We gotta go.
Riding.
AHHHHH!
Go!
Oh my god, it's the guy!
It was the guy up there!
Um...
I think we're in trouble.
Everything's fine Everything's fine I didn't know he was
standing right there
Get out of here Yeah, return to your positions, dummies
This game always gets me Should I just wait out the caution
before I go in there?
I do have stun grenades.
Question.
Is the AK on the top floor or the bottom floor?
If you guys want to...
Oh, you know.
If you guys want to help out a little bit.
The bottom.
Okay.
Bottom, the bottom, the bottom, the bottom.
If I die here, I'm just going to reload the save.
I'm going to go into the main menu.
I'm reload.
Oh my god.
Okay.
The button.
Nothing here.
Which way do you go?
Up or down?
We're dancing.
Don't turn around.
Keep going.
Oh.
Uh.
Uh, is this it?
Yes.
I got it.
We're good.
Don't ding it.
Um.
We're fine.
Uh.
Where's the AK?
Let's get the AK first.
Where is it?
Where's the AK?
Oh, where's the egg?
Are you kidding me?
Get out of here!
Who said you could have come in here?
God.
Where's the AK?
Oh, there it is.
Yippee!
I could have...
It was like just hovered...
It was just under the radar.
Looks like you got an AK.
An AK.
If you wear an enemy's field outfit and carry an AK, you can
pass for one day.
I can!
Listen up, kid.
and don't forget this only the guards in shell one's core
are armed with a k right why is it like that are armed with
the a and 94.
why official right yeah but what if i what if i'm just
taking a walk to disguise yourself as the enemy i'm just
taking a walk from the from the core who cares if i have one
or not who cares oh more bullets oh delicious yum yum and
get the m4 first okay okay they're you know no
let's not leave through there um the enemy cares they care
they're just a little too anal about it i think they're just
a little too like come on it's fine oh like it's whatever
okay this guy is gonna be a bit of a pain no don't come over
here Nothing here.
But now the bridge is all messed up, isn't it?
Now the bridge is all messed up, though.
This guy.
You bastard.
Oh.
We got a few more.
Oh my god.
How's your ammo looking?
Not great.
I'll be honest.
Okay, so aim for the...
What should I be aiming for?
Like lower here?
Like here?
Oh my god.
No!
I shot one!
Spray and pray with the AK.
Oh,
oh my god.
Oh my god.
No, I didn't mean to do that.
Why did you have to move?
Right at that moment.
There we go.
Okay.
Where's the other one?
Oh, my bullets.
Please.
Brighton.
As long as that guy doesn't wake up.
I think we're okay, though.
I think we're mostly okay.
Oh, geez.
What a troublesome spot we're in, everybody.
A bit of an annoyance here.
A bit of a troublesome spot.
But it's okay.
You need more bullets.
I know.
We'll get them somewhere.
They have to keep...
If everybody in Shell 1 uses the bullets, then we also need
to use the bullets.
Oh gosh, I'm scared here.
Oh gosh.
Oh gosh, I hope they don't spot me.
Wait.
Ah!
That sounded a little personal.
The way Snake said that sounded personal.
And being just like, Like, wha!
Riden!
Oh, first we gotta take out this guy.
At the tippy top.
There he is.
First we take out this guy.
Okay.
Now, AK.
I think I can get it from here.
I'm like, I can't aim lower.
So I'm not gonna try.
But this one's coming.
Nice.
And once this one goes away...
Oh!
Thank you!
I like to think Raiden is...
Wait, where'd it go?
Oh my god.
Oh!
That was so close!
Hold on.
Oh, no.
I missed my shot.
It's okay.
I can take it this one, though.
Oh, too high.
Nice.
And this one.
Don't notice me, please.
Got him.
Okay.
I like to think Raiden isn't injured.
He's just floating there, embarrassed.
Like, damn, I effed up.
That was truly my thought process, yes.
Okay.
There we go.
I don't think he's dead either.
He really just looks like he's kind of sad.
But it does look kind of like pretty far maybe, you know?
I love having level two grip.
I love having level two grip, grip, grip.
I love having level two.
Yay!
Alright, let's get suited up, everybody!
N-R-A-K!
Nice.
Here we go.
Get a group.
So I just have to not run into these folks.
Don't be suspicious.
suspicious don't be suspicious don't be suspicious don't be
suspicious don't be suspicious why this camera angle don't
be suspicious don't be suspicious yes don't be suspicious oh
don't be suspicious don't be suspicious where is the nerd i
think it's downstairs in um that one room
A soldier!
Yes!
I'm just a soldier!
Uh...
Spaciba!
There's the eye sensor.
Retinol pattern recognized.
Very good.
You are cleared to enter.
There it is.
Oh well this one's for this floor.
Oh shoot, wait, where's the other one?
Ryden do be like, I love, I do love the whiskey or vodka.
Yep.
Don't be suspicious.
Eat that.
But not being...
Oh, Ryden.
Ryden, your uniform!
Wait, where is it?
Oh, there it is.
Don't be suspicious.
wait let's go back up and get find the nerd there I'm
going in the elevator I have very important business yeah we
got to find the nerd and don't say the bottom right I didn't
play MGS when it came out by any means so I was a bit
surprised that apparently people were not that fond of
riding as a protagonist and it kind of reminded me of how
people didn't like Gohan and DBZ or Nero and DMC kind of
funny how that happens right It's kind of funny how that
happens.
Um, uh, wait.
Don't be suspicious.
Where is the nerd?
Where's the nerd?
Here's a nerdy nerd.
Nerd and out.
I'm nerding out.
Where's the nerd?
There it is.
Don't forget to say nothing here every five seconds.
Nothing here.
Did they come in here?
I don't think so.
Ooh, who's that?
Yeah, I'll take that.
Ooh, la-la.
Oh, my weapon.
Oh my god, there's a cat!
There's a little baby!
Whose locker is this?
Okay.
Let's go this way since there's less people.
Oh, but you come down here.
It makes me scared.
Don't be suspicious.
What's on B2, I don't remember, actually?
Uh, B...
Remember what you're fighting for.
Remember who's waiting for you at home.
Second floor basement.
B2.
I like B1, though.
Wait, computer room.
Wait a second.
Or maybe... Oh, wait.
B2, I think, is where I'm thinking of.
A certain friend is in here, I think.
Maybe?
Wait, where am I?
No, it is B1, isn't it?
No, it's...
Hmm?
Oh, yeah, here we are.
What's up?
Venus and Cancer.
Who's saying all that?
What's up?
Good morning.
Look at that bird!
Venus and Cancer.
Please not!
Why is it showing me this guy?
Oh my god.
Can I help you?
Why are you running?
Why are you running after me?
Oh my god.
Why are we showing the guards fighting?
How?
They're distracted.
and take their stuff.
Oh.
They were distracted.
Fuck.
Oh, shoot.
I got the D-Mic.
Okay.
Oh.
How?
What?
You have the directional microphone.
According to our information, Ames has a pacemaker.
This should make his cardiac pattern fairly distinct.
Use the directional microphone to locate it.
Yes.
Let me get out of here first.
I'm awfully scared.
But boom.
Oh my gosh, that was so close, you guys.
Did you see how close that was?
I almost ran into them, for real.
Ah!
I'm trying to look in the locker.
But this guy is too fast.
He is way too fast.
I don't want to be suspicious or anything, but I need some
bullets.
Please, get out.
There's a magnet!
Wait, she's sitting on top of the locker!
How do I get that?
Oh, I need the M4 first.
Whoa, whoa!
Oh, this is just a little high as well.
How do I get it?
I don't remember.
Do I have to punch it?
But they'll see me punching it, right?
This guy turned around.
Whoa, whoa.
Hey, can you like chill out?
Uh-oh, he's on his way again.
Let's stop.
Wait, maybe I can, maybe I have time.
Wait.
Oh, I don't have time.
He's on my butt.
On the PS2, yeah.
Damn.
You know what?
It's fine.
I give up.
We got what we needed.
Crown guy is too scary, he's too unpredictable.
Good job, guys.
Good job, team.
The D-mic on the bird.
If I use it here...
Can I hear from...
Wait.
Where's my uniform?
There it is.
If I use it here...
Can I hear it?
It's a bird.
I can hear the guy walking.
A ripped nudie mag.
It's okay.
I have plenty of those already.
B1.
Alright.
This area is a little tricky.
Wait, hold on.
I've got to see his pattern real quick first.
Okay.
So he does have a second where he...
Um.
Okay.
And then he comes up.
Whoa, whoa.
Why are you coming all the way over here?
Okay.
I think once he turns around, I can get him, though.
Wait.
Yeah.
Okay.
What the?
There we go.
All right, come here, baby.
Come here, little guy.
La la la la la la la.
Cover you.
Just gonna use your face for a second.
Oh, he needs to be awake.
Okay.
I'll put him in the locker.
Next try.
He needs...
Oh, yeah.
What?
Just open his eyes.
Use your fingers.
Just like...
Just, like, open his eyes, you know?
Oh, wrong gun.
Next guy is going to come out, right?
Like, just use it.
Just pry his eyes open with your fingers.
It'll work, right?
Okay, I'm so done with you, please.
Oh, my gosh.
Let's see now.
Sorry, I just had to...
get rid of a pesky fly
hello hello fellow soldiers we're all fellow soldiers here
we're all fellow soldiers i think i need to get that guy to
come back out i think i need to um nice uh do this part
again need the m4 Swap me like a fly No, it's just people
like Yelling at me at the game Like I get it Sorry if I
forgot some certain parts of the game You know, but like you
don't need to Go in all caps being like No, it's okay It's
okay Oh, I should have knocked Oh, you're so right VTuber,
why?
Why VTuber?
why oh
my gosh i didn't realize this guy comes up here why did you
forget why did you forget to to do that what vtuber why do
you have your weapon out vtuber why don't you knock instead
vtuber okay now um let's see uh actually i'm gonna code
because I want to see what Pliskin says.
No response!
Colonel?
You're on B1 of the Shell 1 corner.
I am!
Aims is being held in the hall.
Colonel, you're so boring in this game.
You'll have to get through a door protected by a retinal
scanner security system.
Right.
Get past the retinal scanner and infiltrate the hall.
I thought it was an actual fly and was going to say, damn,
it should have been me who got slapped by my head.
Yeah, he's just so soulless.
What can I do for you, Jack?
All he cares about is the mission.
It's like Shadow Moses changed him or something.
What happened to you, Colonel?
Ignore the Elpers.
No, I don't mind a little bit of Elping.
It's just when I'm like, you know, trying to remember stuff
and people like yell at me about it.
Jack, how's the mission going?
It's great.
Oh, fine.
it look I really don't feel like talking about the mission
at least with you I want to talk about something else
something okay then let's talk about you yeah yeah your
least favorite subject no like what anything tell me
something about yourself how self-centered I can't think of
anything interesting to say why do you want to talk about me
so badly because I'm curious but why is it Really that
strange to want to know more about someone you love?
I'm self-centered.
You know, sometimes I...
Such an egotistical woman.
Oh, look.
Now we're talking about me, not you.
Why won't you tell me anything about what you were like as a
child?
What kind of things you like to do?
What kind of people your parents were?
Do you even like her, Ryden?
I've never heard you talk about any of that.
Oh, my God.
Don't you think it's just a little bit unusual that I don't
know anything about my own boyfriend's past rose when i get
back i'll tell you everything everything is that a promise
oh red that's a death flag that's a death flag right there
okay all right if i die i'm just gonna reload every time
okay i have to hold up this guy though i have to hold him up
okay this part's so annoying
when he's in front of it right Okay, um, can I, do I use the
AK or can I use my gun?
There we go.
Uh, do it.
Do the thing.
Do, oh, I'm out of my uniform.
Do it.
Uh.
Okay.
Oh, uh, whoops.
Uh, come here.
Come here, you.
Use your eyes.
Your eyes!
Oh, bug.
Yeah, I accidentally tranked him, and it took effect.
It's okay.
We'll just go through it again.
No worries.
Coolant spray to wake him up, but that's so rude.
That's so rude.
We almost had him.
Yeah, but that's okay, we can get him again.
No problem.
Come on, man.
Come on.
There he comes.
Worst shift ever.
Okay.
Oh my god, that scared me.
Freeze.
Oh,
now I did it again!
Oh!
Retinal pattern recognized.
You are cleared to enter.
You know what?
If it works, it works.
Whatever works, works.
Alright, we got our AK.
We're gonna be real sneaky here.
We're gonna look for aims.
We're gonna say, you must be aims.
You must be aims.
We got our direct.
directional mic.
We're coming down.
We're looking all sneaky and such.
Ah, yeah.
You must be Ames.
I'm gonna listen to half Johnny, half the conversation.
One of those hostages in there is Ames.
I know.
The only thing we know is that Ames wears a pacemaker.
Okay.
The music in here is so cool.
So use the directional microphone to locate him.
Once you recognize Ames by his heartbeat, keep the
microphone pointed toward him.
Then push the action button and call out to him.
He must be Ames.
If it really is Ames, he should respond in some way.
What if it's the wrong person?
The guards may get suspicious and come running instead.
I kind of want to see though.
Security could get tighter too.
I'll just have to do the room again, right?
Or you take the risk.
I want to see actually.
Don't call out to a hostage with the action button until
you're fairly sure Well, what happens if I do?
It'll be funny.
Switch the microphone for an AK and get out of there before
a guard gets suspicious.
If you're discovered inside, they'll cut off your retreat
and call in the reinforcements.
You won't make it out of the room.
The mission will be over if you're discovered.
Okay.
Don your disguise and look for aims while deflecting the
enemy's suspicion.
I'm so not suspicious.
I feel like we're going to hear that a lot.
But I just want to walk around and check out these guys for
a bit.
Can I walk on top of you?
Sorry.
Excuse me.
I'm looting a little bit.
I'm grabbing stuff first.
Recording the problems in the hall on B1 and the shell one
core.
The flag is on backwards.
I know there's patches to fix that.
You guys see that?
Oops.
Excuse me.
How many are there?
Two?
Two guys?
One guy?
Oh!
Oh my god.
Ryden.
What the hell?
This guy tripped me!
Where's my uniform?
Oh, here.
That guy tripped me!
What a jerk!
Okay.
Reposing no problems in the hall on B1, in the Shell 1 core.
Your aims, aren't you?
They weren't suspicious.
Hey, why didn't you say anything?
Talk, man.
Trying to ask you if your aims are not.
Come on, are you aims or not?
Say something.
Damn it.
Hmm.
Oh.
Hold on, I want to talk to that lady.
I'm also supposed to be here.
Are you Ames?
You're Ames, aren't you?
Oh.
Are you Ames?
I get so upset.
Your aims, aren't you?
No.
Nothing.
Nothing here.
I'm just like you.
Nothing.
Reporting no problems in the hall on B1, in the Shell 1
core.
In the B1, Shell 1.
anybody else do anything interesting?
Where is Jennifer?
I don't know.
Jenny.
Is that?
That's her right there.
I've been trying to get to her though.
I think.
This is her.
It's gotta be her.
Your aims, aren't you?
My name's Jennifer.
I don't know why it's so funny.
Oh.
Your aims, aren't you?
I knew it was him the whole time.
My name's Jennifer.
Aim your mic at her and click L3.
Wait, what?
I knew it was him the whole time.
Sherman?
Okay.
Keep still and listen to me.
I'm not a terrorist.
What happens if you do that, though?
I'm taking off the tape.
Stay quiet.
Yeah!
Must be names.
No, I actually remembered where he was.
But I don't remember.
There's some things that I remember and some things that I
don't about this game.
It's so funny.
Maybe because I really like this part.
No, I was set in by the Lali Lulelo.
Just like you.
Lali Lulelo.
Uh-oh.
Oh, no!
You're here to find out where the president is.
They always are watching me!
It's always Acelot.
Communications first.
Yeah What are you why are you acting like you don't know
what that is right and talk when it comes to safety come on
right in Why do you act like you don't know what that is?
Hi, you'll never listen in on my thoughts.
I said I'm right here.
Do you really know where the president is?
Almost certainly he was moved to the first floor of shell
to's core section the first floor the core of shell?
Is he still there?
I don't know.
I can't get a response.
Uh-oh.
Like the other hostages.
A hostage was killed in retaliation after the Sea of Ten
disaster.
Wait, what?
Huh?
Did they lie about the hostage getting killed?
They won't touch the president.
What makes you so sure?
The case.
You mean the nuclear button they took?
Right.
And the case won't do a thing by itself.
That case may be the single most advanced.
example of a weapons fail-safe system how you know i am
password is nothing less than the physiological data of the
u.s president physiological data the president's learning
words for the first time brainwave pattern blood pressure
and so on are constantly monitored and relayed by his
internal nanomachines this information along with the dna
pattern serve as a biometric password unbreakable even by
the latest parallel processor supercomputers the password
entry at cannot be performed unless brainwave patterns and
heartbeats fall within normal parameters rendering chemical
and other forms of coercion impractical in other words the
login must be made of the president's own free will so smart
the input must also be reconfirmed hourly even after the
initial login if a valid confirmation is not forthcoming the
system will automatically cancel the login that's why they
can't harm the president yeah at least until the bird flies
Is there really a new model of Metal Gear?
Oh yeah, what does that mean until the bird flies?
The black case serves as the launch key to Metal Gear as
well.
Why would they hide Metal Gear in an offshore plant?
Hmm.
Haven't they told you anything?
This is getting, this is so much deja vu.
This is so much deja vu!
First, Solid Snake isn't told anything.
The big shell was built specifically for the development of
a new Metal Gear model.
The inspection tool was to check its progress.
What's going on around here?
I love riding so much.
He's such a weenie.
I can't.
Nose for I, too.
Oh my god, he looks just like Dracula.
Okay, I'm gonna be sneaky.
No, that's solid snake.
You spelled it wrong.
Jeremy, you spelled it wrong.
Solid snake.
Oh, dang it.
No.
fat man is dead it doesn't matter king why did he betray us
oh to come all the way to New York just to get hit with a
bowel attack and his background reject just in case you
think he was working for them we can't discount the
possibility especially with that intruder still at large yes
yes and the sneaking suits yes you know more about those
suits than i do but foxhound was disbanded because he's a
solid snake oh this one's worse than that one up in alaska
i'm to think of it that commander chick really reminded me
of someone who is she like again what are you he's thinking
of her the circulation system for the contaminated water has
been damaged the water being drawn in is overflowing and the
lower block of the central section commander check he's
thinking of Merrill she's like her now that's a time I'd
like to forget ridiculous that I had to get Jack for
everything that was on me when I think about it that's when
everything started to hit the skids it's a shame Up to that
point, I was steady cruising on the elite course.
Oh, here we go again.
Syntax and IR sensors are already in place.
Any effect on it?
No.
He's in there fighting for his life.
His eyes?
Oh, no!
One hour we'll need a confirmation from him.
His work is done after that.
No, no!
Make sure you keep him alive until then.
Yes, I know.
Yes, sir.
its activation almost complete the code has already been
entered oh no now is for the girl to start the system a girl
the usual method i assume he's fighting his own battles
drugs took care of everything drugs only a few more steps to
outer heaven oh my god look at him he's daydreaming right
there still that russian crew is a pretty decent bunch ninja
shala shaska i cannot even guess what about you i looked
into olga don't cast suspicion where it isn't due where it
isn't due when you watched my father die and did nothing oh
two years ago olga let it go i read the case file for shadow
moses by the way yeah olga how could you suspect me i know
that the ninja is not one of my men yeah meaningful you make
that sound Sergei we're still alive let it go oh god it's
been two years your dad it was just your dad come on Sergei
was my best friend if you sell us out i'll kill you myself
look at them listen daughter of Sergei don't ever let me see
your gun pointed at me again if you wish i'll put a bullet
in your back instead oh i took you both in when no one else
would you think any government would have you as irregular
in this political climate the worst kind of wet works maybe
but even that's doubtful i recommend against switching camps
you've nowhere left to go oh
bye-bye the president's escort guys get on my nerves
whatever for now just got to hang in there oh you got this
daddy oh there's no paper it's happening again this damn
right arm liquid it's almost as if it's having its revenge
how much do you think we spent on that arm and Leon the best
transplant surgery team in the world I never trust a
Frenchman Johnny, are you okay in there?
There's something going on.
The incidents are becoming more frequent.
Maybe that man's presence.
Oh, what man?
Ocelot, I leave this place in your hands.
I have the intruder to take care of.
Yes, King.
Well, I hope Johnny's okay.
Johnny's on his own battlefield.
It's true.
You must be Ames.
Is that really Solid Snake?
That's what he claims.
Johnny's fighting his own liquid right now.
See you.
Solid Snake did die.
But he's also here in the shell.
It makes no sense.
What?
Two of them.
Yippee!
Two of them!
I wish there were more Solid Snakes.
Anyway.
What did you manage to catch?
they said password input was complete but I thought so and
then there was also this guy he was just had to be made by
the president willingly that's right yes this means the
president is cooperating with them it would have to be yes
why why tired of being a puppet but it wasn't a smart move
to betray us hmm we're running out of time they will fire a
nuke you know what you need to do before then fire the nuke
but it's nowhere close to the ransom deadline yeah ransom 30
billion dollars in cash why does nobody know what this
ransom is the nuclear strike is not a threat it's been the
objective all along they plan to slaughter millions of
people no a high altitude detonation you've heard of the
Compton effect total it's gonna be raining nuclear bits by
the emma pulse textbook answer well when an average nuclear
warhead goes off within the atmosphere the result is an
electromagnetic pulse of of 50 billion megawatts the emma
field can reach tens of thousands of volts per meter and
most electronic equipment will be toast in an instant if one
of the key movers of world economy stops functioning it
could mean the beginning of a global depression but that
isn't their aim i'm already too depressed i can't be any
more depressed please pull it offline and turn it into some
kind of a republic hence the sons of liberty i suppose sons
of liberty I'm going offline.
I'm going offline.
Wrong movie.
They said the name of the game.
Sons of Liberty.
Okay.
How do I know which pocket?
Oh, thanks.
You'll be able to unlock doors of up to level 3 security.
Use it to get to Shell 2.
Okay.
Take care of the president before they launch the nuke.
Ah!
He's on his way.
He's coming.
He's looking really sassy.
He's coming here.
Pick up your AK.
Stop yelling at me, Ames!
He's gonna hear you!
I got my AK.
Oh.
That was so bad.
That was it.
Um.
What do you think you're doing?
Oh, nothing, sir.
I asked him to remove these.
I'm ill, you see.
I always knew that the DIA turned out second-rate liars.
What are you talking about?
No need for denials.
We know what you are, Colonel Ames.
You know what I am.
They knew that the president was planning to betray them.
So they sent you in to keep tabs on him.
Am I right?
A vampire.
You.
Sorry, Colonel.
You failed to carry out your duties.
I will never escape the Lali Lulule.
No!
The Lulule Lul!
What the?
Oh!
Wait, it's not IBS, is it?
Uh-oh.
You,
which team are you with?
Ah.
Show me your face.
You know who he is.
No.
Not one of mine.
Uh, you know me.
What are you talking about?
Identify yourself.
Billy, we've gone way back.
Oh my gosh, she's so beautiful.
That hair flip.
Ah!
Oh, oh, get his arm!
Oh, not this time.
Ah!
It's that ninja!
Oh, my name is Jennifer!
Oh!
Hurry, get away!
Jennifer, are you okay?
You, but you died!
Hey Fox!
Yay!
Okay, I'm gonna get out of here!
Yep, don't mind me, I'm getting out!
Okay.
my other arm.
Wait.
Ah!
Ames is dead.
Now, don't get me out!
Hmm.
That's unfortunate.
However, we do at least know where the president is.
So there really is a new type of metal gear in this place?
Apparently.
No.
We're still looking into it.
I've also been told that the nuclear strike was what the
terrorists were after from the start.
Not the 30 billion I'm scared It was a cover-up all along
Colonel, what are you keeping from me?
Yep, you told me about the 30 billion It's not as though I'm
told all the facts either Uh-huh I'm pulling in all the
favors I can Uh-huh Where you, this has happened This is all
deja vu From Shadow Moses We can take it That they've
completed the password entry And are preparing Metal Gear
for nuclear strike Get to the president as soon as possible
is cooperating with them.
According to Ames, yes.
Ames?
To Ames.
There's something else going on here.
And the president may be able to tell you what it is when
you see him in person.
Once they get the confirmation for nuclear launch, they'll
do it.
You need to rescue the president before them.
Okay.
Jack, I agree with the Colonel.
You need to protect the president for now.
Protect the president.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, I'm not ready.
I'm a box.
I'm just a box.
I have the same...
Oh.
Though I don't.
I'm a box.
Where do I go from here, actually?
Colonel, where am I going?
To use the elevator.
I know how to use the elevator, Colonel.
When the panel appears, oh my god, please.
Jesus, Lauren, press the enter button.
and the elevator will start moving.
Rose, don't join in!
You can use the right analog stick to surveying your
surroundings.
Keep an eye out for approaching enemies.
Moshi Moshi!
Right, this is not good.
Enemies in Shell 1 are systematically searching for you.
It looks like they've tightened security considerably.
Watch yourself.
Where do I go?
Get out of Shell 1.
Okay.
According to Ames, the president is on the first floor of
Shell 2's core.
Cross the connecting bridge from the north side of Strut D
to get to Shell 2.
That's where you need to go.
Um, also Pliskin?
Where are you?
Okay.
Strut D.
That way.
Do I have to go out through...
Through E then and then go to D?
Wait.
Was I able to make it there?
Trying to remember.
Do I have to go out this way?
Wait, this BC connecting is broken, right?
And so I need to go to this way.
Yeah, the other one's destroyed.
Okay, so we just gotta...
We just gotta somehow get out of here.
Without being noticed.
Just a box.
Oh gosh, now there's other people coming too!
Get out of here!
Go- turn- turn around!
Turn around!
I don't want your sass!
Okay.
I need you to go away.
There we go.
Perfect timing.
Awesome.
Not perfect timing.
Eee!
Oh god.
Oh shit.
Um.
Nothing here.
Oh my god.
How?
Where's the guy that's supposed to be up there?
Oh, shoot.
There he is, I see him now.
Oh my goodness.
Wait, I don't want to get caught.
Don't see me.
There he is.
Snipe him!
snipe up from here over a little over a little there damn
close he's don't look don't look mister um it's okay let's
just let's take these out first right yeah this who cares
about that guy oh it's on the other side don't shoot him no
no no just checked into my hotel lolly Lule Long Beach.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Don't watch me at the hotel.
That's so funny.
Okay.
Can I get him now?
Oh, come on.
There we go.
See you guys.
I have a god aim.
Most of the time.
Oh.
God aim.
God.
Aim.
Yeah.
And one more.
This one's a little tricky.
He's a little fast.
He's a little furious.
Yeah!
Talking about baby!
Am I good over here or...
Are there more bombs?
Run, Ryden!
Just run!
We're good.
That was really cool.
wait how am i supposed to get wait
what's inside here oh i know it's inside here
the parcel room there's so many more guys though wait a
second wait they're gonna come running this way they won't
right yeah Okay, we're good.
Okay, this way.
Oh shoot, it's level five!
Wait.
Where's my zone of the Enders box?
I want my own.
Section would be a lot cooler with a skateboard.
I think you're right.
Oh wait, do I just go to this?
inside
here.
Eon falls asleep.
It might be a god gamer sometimes, you guys.
Oh wait, the sniper guy up here.
Oh, he'll leave eventually though.
I think.
He leaves eventually.
Why did I not go to D again earlier?
Oh wait, I did go to D because this is the room with the...
I remember this room.
Oh my gosh, wait.
Uh...
Is he gonna come up?
I'm waiting for the other guy to leave too.
Not gonna lie.
Yeah, I'm waiting for the sniper guy to take a nap or...
Take a...
Take a walk!
But there's this guy down here.
Will he hear me?
Does he come up?
The stairs?
Oh, he left!
but there's two of them.
Take a hike, Bozo.
Oh my gosh.
It's this one over here, right?
I'm here.
I'm heading on over.
Oh.
Oh!
Oh, I need the sniper!
Can you hear me?
Yeah.
Where have you been?
I'm in Strut H right now.
How's the situation over there?
We have a lead on the president's location.
Where is he?
First floor.
I'm cut off from the core where I am.
It's a mess here.
Alright.
I'm on my way to Shell 2 right now.
Wait!
There are IR sensors in place on the connecting bridge
between Shells 1 and 2.
will go off I heard them talking about that target the
control units and destroy them did I I think I was too busy
thinking of Johnny what do the controlled units look like
take a look with your binoculars okay whoa that's them that
okay get a really good look at it oh I guess uh must be the
control I guess Raiden didn't um ever set them off it was
There was always Solid Snake that took them out first.
Is this, you need a PSG?
Yeah, wait.
Where do I get that PSG?
Pliscan!
Don't try to shoot out control units with the handgun when
the distance is too great.
The weapon doesn't have that kind of range.
Use the sniper rifle.
Where is it?
I saw a PSG-1 in the storage room on Strut F.
No.
There should be one left, so go and grab it.
I hate this game.
Just go.
Let's just leave.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, back to Strut F.
At least it's not so difficult.
Wait, where are we at?
E.
F.
This is the one with our little...
sniper friend you can't see me hey oh there's two of them
what are you doing up there since when were there two of
them the guy came strolling out as if I wouldn't even notice
that's so funny here I go they're talking having a nice
little conversation in the middle he was it did look like he
I was surrendering for a second.
Okay.
Oh.
Bucks.
So glad this guy is blind.
Nothing here.
Are you gonna look to the left?
Intruder to the left.
Intruder to the right.
At least getting through here is like so not bad, you know.
Hold on, I don't want to...
There we go.
Just to be on the...
Aering on the side of caution.
No, I don't know.
You can fast travel.
That's true.
Oh, yeah.
But...
I don't know what boxes I have.
Oh, to electric appliances.
Is that where I need to go?
Daily supplies?
Action figures!
Wait, what does this one look like?
I think all the things are gone though, it's just him.
Never mind, I hear them, they're not gone.
Yeah!
Oh my god, that was so close.
Holy cow!
That was so close.
Oh my god, please, please, fingers.
There we go.
that was so close oh it's this okay I think I have to box it
he does leave eventually though pretty sure pretty sure he
leaves eventually but I need to take these guys out first I
do these dang ciphers why is it always auto aim to up can
you right in What?
No!
Oh shoot.
I'm actually in trouble now.
Ah!
They won't come this way.
Ouchie, ouchie, ouchie.
Yeah!
Oh, how did we both...
Raiden, Raiden!
Cool!
Oh, we are so in trouble.
Um, Raiden?
Down?
Down.
Goodbye, sweet.
With cruel world.
Right.
Come in.
You know what?
Sometimes it's just easier.
Oh, gosh.
I have to start all the way over here, though.
I'm so stupid.
I should have just killed myself from the beginning.
I'm going out on my own terms.
Ah, man.
I have to go all the way back, though, because I'm an idiot.
Oh, these guys are still out.
Where's the entrance service?
Anyway.
They slept through the alert.
Nobody let them know.
Who?
Oh, that's the wrong thing.
Nothing here.
Alright, we won't get caught this time, guys.
Me, I'm just like, oh, this way's not so bad!
It's whatever!
It's not so bad!
Are they all back?
Are all the things back?
Yep.
Dang it.
No, and I have to worry about this guy seeing it too!
No, man.
He'll see it if I shoot it.
direction I suppose so like now he would see it right no why
did you only see it before what I
have a question will they see well the I'm too nervous to go
because the things will I think they'll see my box we heard
the shots ah That would make more sense.
If it was the shots he heard.
My D key is...
D?
My square key is acting funky.
A little bit.
Did he leave?
Anyway.
Pressure sensitive issue?
I think so.
Hmm.
Top floor?
Grenade launcher top left room.
PSG middle right room.
Wes!
You didn't have to do that.
You didn't have to tell me where everything is.
You didn't have to tell me.
You didn't have to do that.
See, I'm like pushing down on it, but it's really...
It's giving me a hard time!
No!
It's not my fault!
My controller!
No!
My controller is fucking up!
Oh gosh.
No!
I'm really pushing down on it, I am!
Oh, oh.
My health.
It's been a while since I've like attached the ration.
Yeah, I'm bleeding out.
Oh, that one was me.
Um, okay.
Okay, all right, we got this now.
I don't know why it's giving me such trouble all of a
sudden.
But it is.
You know what, I think I'm just gonna run for it, though.
After this guy leaves.
I forgot he looked this way.
This is the run.
Giga Darkman!
You jinxed it!
You jinxed it.
Does anyone actually use the...
I think you use the bandage if you can't like lay down at
the moment, you know what I mean?
If you're just like, oh I don't have a chance to to use you
know what i mean play more c4 c4 um no
more c4 but no no psg no psg
But there's lockers in here.
How fast does he turn around on this guy?
Too fast for me.
Oh, now I'm like trapped here too.
It feels like...
Oh gosh, I'm scared.
get him i'm trapped in this room no where's he go where is
he actually okay that guy goes upstairs is he coming back
this guy over here oh oh here he is he's coming back now he
is
my memory did not serve i trusted you
One floor down?
Shoot.
Wait, no.
We already went in.
Is it the same room as before?
Or is it the one on the left?
I guess maybe then.
I'm just gonna box it.
Once he walks away.
No, not yet.
Maybe over here?
Ah!
RGB!
What the heck is this?
Hello?
Are you gonna get up there?
There we go.
We're a gamer?
RGB.
Oh, the grenade launcher.
The thing you talked about.
Okay, so we do have to go downstairs.
Okay.
gaming.
Oh my gosh, I'm just gonna blow everybody up in here.
That would be kind of awesome, though.
That would be kind of hardcore.
Not downstairs.
M4!
Oh, this...
I see it.
Oh!
What's in there?
Wait a second.
Can I shut this off?
Everybody shield your eyes!
Oh, it hurts, it hurts, it hurts, it hurts, it hurts, it
hurts, it hurts, it hurts!
Okay.
We got damn four.
Assault rifle.
What if I put on their outfit?
Oh, I don't have it anymore.
Oh, what if I put on their outfit?
Oh.
I'm still...
My face is shut.
What's in here?
What the?
It's ammo!
Why is this in here?
Why is there PSG ammo in the hole?
Hello?
Is the PSG in here?
No, but M4 ammoers.
Is it upstairs?
I'm still confused.
most secret ammo.
Actually, though.
Nothing here.
Okay, if there's nothing here, you can leave.
Oh, oh, oh.
Now go up.
Go up.
I love being a box.
And here.
I'm grabbing everything but what I need.
I'm literally grabbing everything but what I need right now.
Ah!
There's PSG ammo everywhere!
It wasn't this room, right?
What was in here?
There's just not nothing in here.
Oh wait, there's a tunnel.
There is something here.
Hold on.
If I swear, if there's PSG ammo at the end of this, I'm
gonna scream.
Oh, this is that...
Wait.
Oh.
Wait, am I downstairs?
Don't look this way.
Am I downstairs now?
Interesting.
I think that's it.
Yippee!
Wait, I'm still upstairs.
Where the hell am I?
Where am I?
Head to the connecting bridge between shells one and two.
I'm gonna go collect all that stuff though first.
Nothing here.
Wait, I bet there's ammo in there.
Here I go.
I gotta go check.
What's this?
Oh!
Shut up!
up!
We got a tranquilizer version!
Yo!
I had no idea that was here.
Nothing here.
My treasure is here.
Let's go!
We'll wait for this guy to leave.
I'm
just gonna go back around actually i'm just gonna go back
through here i know some of you might be saying why because
i also want to get that ammo but also
because um i feel safer the other way
that guy's below us yeah here get that ammo there we go
Don't come this way.
No one.
Um, while...
While the security...
While the caution goes down, I'm gonna go grab some tea real
quick.
What time is it?
Oh my gosh, it's almost been five hours!
I have to stop soon, though.
Well, I can maybe go shoot those bombs, and then...
Maybe I'll shoot the bombs next time.
Holy cow.
Let's let this caution run out.
I'm going to, like I said, I'm going to be right back.
I'm going to grab some tea.
And...
You know what comes after the bombs.
I know, that's why I'm like, maybe I will save the bombs for
next time.
time because I think I don't want to get caught in whatever
might happen.
Wink, wink.
Wink.
We can save that special iconic sand for next time, I think.
Okay, BRB.
Are you in here with me?
Don't sniff that.
Come here.
little girl you want to be in my chair no she got out of my
chair i'm back
okay anyway not nothing here nothing here wasn't that so
silly everybody wasn't that such a silly occurrence oh my
gosh that guy has hawk eyes that guy i think he i think he
saw what he shouldn't have seen that guy's vision is too
good gotta take him out yeah he's wall hacking for real wait
does he turn around or no he walks down okay this is my
chance we
did it give me Those boxes you see from the vent, the logo
is McFarlane Toys.
Oh, it is!
Yeah, I do know their figures are really ugly.
Affectionate.
There he is.
I think all the ciphers are gone, so I think we're good.
They were okay at the moment.
They were...
They just have...
They just look...
They just...
Are we going for the bombs or not?
Oh, you're right!
Um, I'm going to go to there and I'm going to save at there.
So that, um...
When I start the game, we're right there.
You know what I mean?
So I'm gonna go there.
And we're gonna save.
Right outside the door.
Nothing here.
Oh, not yet.
Not right here.
We're gonna have to wait for this guy to take a nap again.
Our little...
Our little, little sniper man.
Oh wait, there's two of them there!
Oh yeah, I forgot that there's two of them.
We can wait for both of them to leave.
go sometimes at some point.
There, he leaves.
He leaves.
Hmm.
I could.
They're stylized.
Did I miss Fat Man?
Yeah, I'm sorry.
Get out of here.
Go.
Psh.
Stop staring.
Sorry, I know I could go and like Oh.
Wait, this guy comes back.
Excuse me.
Take a hike!
There's no stretching on the job.
Gosh.
These guys are ridiculous.
They just act like there's no...
Nobody to worry about over here, you know?
Okay, now we get through Stretty.
What are you doing, Paz?
Oh, she's being a curious girl.
She's being a little curious cat, you know.
As she does.
and through okay now I can save ah shell one shell two
connecting bridge baby let's talk to Pliskin don't try to
shoot out control units with the handgun when the distance
is oh yeah he told me this the weapon doesn't have that kind
of range yeah use the PSG one to take out those control
units Okay.
Right, and what you see there is a booby trap.
Colonel said booby.
The Semtex will detonate if the IR beam from the sensor is
disturbed.
Whatever you do, don't touch the IR beam.
But there's no way to get through there without crossing the
beam.
Mutualize all the control units for the IR sensor.
Those control units and the distance are obviously out of
handgun range.
What do I do then?
use the sniper rifle to take them out i got it use the psg1
sniper rifle to shoot out control units that are farther
away booby was never part of the simulation all right rose
what can i do for you jack i'm just saving and then i'm
gonna quit gosh already already i what nine out eight almost
nine hours i'm so slow with this game thank you guys for
being patient with me you're probably doing fine but don't
get discouraged another lieutenant jg pliskin is with you
too you'll be all right what's wrong salute to the solid
metal don't give me that every time you say nothing it's
always something what's wrong it's just that you know you
seem to think pretty highly oh yeah pliskin's the kind of
guy you can really depend on isn't he Ooh!
What?
What's up with this guy?
Yeah, Pliskin is one heck of a man, isn't he?
He's so cool, so confident.
Yeah.
But he's nowhere near as cool as you.
He'll always be my number one.
What's up with this guy?
But that's not what I meant.
Aww.
You know, you're kind of cute sometimes.
Bye, Jack.
She loves her Tundere boyfriend.
So next time!
take these out?
Wait, how do I use this again?
Zoom it.
Sons of liberty!
How do I see it, though?
Why, if I crouch this?
I wish I could crouch with the thing, you know?
That's it right there, isn't it?
And we have... How many are there?
Two?
Three.
Six.
Sons of Liberty.
Something that you would complete the game in under 30
minutes, but I think we're pretty close to that mark.
Yeah, we're so close.
I think I have, I mean, I know I have quite a ways to go.
But that's okay.
This kind of game, there's so much going on.
So I don't mind taking it a little bit more slowly.
238 is my record.
Holy cow.
But I get, I feel like the more I play, I mean, each time I
play, like, I haven't beat this game very many times.
But I get a little bit more used to it every time.
So, you know.
Happy I can catch a stream on my birthday.
Oh my gosh, Jack!
Happy birthday!
Thank you for streaming my favorite game.
What's up, Jack?
What is that flag?
It's the Sons of Liberty flag.
See?
Sons of Liberty.
I love that the flag in the other room is backwards.
Oh my god, take out that guy, too.
Look at that.
Little cipher.
Am I wrong or can he move the flag with the second
controller?
I don't think you can.
Wait, with second controller.
With a second controller?
Wait, no, really?
If I plugged in a second controller right now, I'd be able
to control it.
Oh, sorry.
Good job, Jackal.
I mean, Ryden.
My name is Ryden.
Codename Ryden.
Codename.
Alright, I'm gonna go out with a bag!
I did save, right?
What can I do for you, Jack?
I did save.
Yeah.
What are you doing, little girl?
Why are you running all around?
She wanted into my room so bad.
What if she'll say anything else, though?
Round.
Yes!
Ah, yeah!
This is why I always try to save as much as possible in this
game.
Because I'm curious, more so than before, does it really
bother you that much?
There must be some things you don't want to say.
Like what?
You know, those things you don't want to say.
Those things you don't want to say!
Hmm, what you say.
Like that you've been married before, that you're 80 years
old, that you used to be a woman.
80 years old!
What exactly is it you won't tell me?
Do you think I'd hate you if I knew?
Do you really have that little faith in me?
Pineapple on pizza?
No, it's nothing like that.
Then what is it?
Give it up already.
It really bothers me.
That's why his hair is white.
The fact that there's a side of you I don't know.
Sometimes I just can't help myself.
You've got me right now.
Isn't that enough?
No, it's not.
I'm sorry.
I know I'm being greedy, but it's just not enough.
She does not know the size.
Rose, I, this is a life or death situation out here.
While you're in your cushy little, your, your cozy room, we
are just in front of a monitor.
I am fighting for my life and you're not helping my mental
situation.
Gosh, I love them.
Oh, I love, I eat it up.
I eat it up.
This one's for you, Rose.
Ah!
Oh.
Righten.
You haven't destroyed all the control units yet.
Use the first person view or the sniper scope to look
around.
Colonel, please just let me kill myself.
Ah!
What the hell happened?
Righten.
Righten!
Yay!
Now we can exit.
I tried to do a cool flip into the oh well that one's for
you Rose wow my eyes oh it's so bright ah thank you guys for
joining me for part 2 of MGS 2 um next time I don't know
where how far we'll get maybe two more streams I don't know
actually um how much more We have...
We have what's coming up in a second.
I won't be able to catch streams for a while since I'm
leaving on a European cruise.
We are late!
I just want to wish you a happy anniversary since I'm going
to miss it.
Hope you have a great time.
Oh, thank you!
I hope you have fun as well.
Oh, hold on.
I gotta not do this because it gets my stream copyrighted.
It gets my stream copyrighted.
Great time on your cruise!
Oh my gosh.
Um, yeah.
Thanks for...
Thanks for the autosoup.
I really appreciate it.
Um...
One of my favorite parts of this game.
Riding on a world-changing life or death mission.
Rose, this is the perfect time to talk about us.
I know, it's so great.
Uh, yeah.
What else?
Why do I have?
I'm trying to think of the order.
We do...
What's coming up next?
That is not Solid Snake.
We have the President.
We have Swimmy Swim Swim Time.
We have Another Sniper Time.
We have
Naked.
Oh no, wait, I'm missing.
I'm missing.
Oh, we have We have a guy That is...
Hey, I'm not trying not to say names, you guys.
I'm trying not to say names.
Stop, stop, stop, stop, stop.
I'm trying to be spoiler-free.
I skipped a...
Yes, but yes, we have a...
We have a guy that is a little slippery.
Then we have...
Uh, Sniper Time.
Naked Time.
Then we have...
Crazy Time.
Then we have Let Her Rip Time.
Potentially you could finish next stream.
Now that I'm thinking about it, it's not as much as I
thought it was.
Maybe if I, like, go a little bit longer and if I play well.
There's not as much as I I thought that there was, actually.
I think cutscenes will also add a bunch to it.
Crazy time is crazy!
I can't wait!
Depends on how long certain parts take.
Yeah, yeah.
So, eight hours or so to go?
Doesn't seem so bad.
Probably do it.
Next week, I think.
Escort hallway.
Don't worry.
I one-timed it last time.
I can do this.
Thank you guys for hanging out with me tonight.
I will be gone the next two days.
I will be streaming again.
again on Sunday.
Monday, I don't think I will be able to stream either.
But Tuesday, I have stream.
And Wednesday is my anniversary.
Yippee!
So, next weekend is also quite busy because I am attending
another convention.
But I will fit in some streams when I can.
This convention has me quite busy, actually.
It's in Texas.
If you're in Texas and you want to come hang out with me,
He'll be doing a panel as well with Ayami Sensei.
Yeah.
I think every weekend up until a point is like a different
event or convention.
It's kind of crazy for me.
But oh, if also you're at MGSCon this weekend, there will be
a little interview with me.
And you can also ask me some questions.
It's kind of a short little thing.
minute slot.
I'm not like a guest or anything.
It's just like a short little how'd you get into Metal Gear?
And then if anybody has some questions and things like that.
But you can see me at MGS God!
Yippee!
Um, and can we drop off any gifts for you there?
Ah, I don't really have a way to accept gifts, so uh, I
don't know.
I don't think so.
I'm sorry.
Um, yeah.
time for po box no no okay i'm gonna go to sleep and you
guys uh have a good night have a good have a good one thank
you guys thank you thank you thank you for a fun time bye
bye bye bye